Hey everyone, so we have a really awesome episode. I think a lot of folks have tried, and we were just talking about this before we started recording, have tried virtual reality and have even tried augmented reality and may not have even known it. That's what it was called. And so we're going to really dive into this feature. I think a lot of folks have called VR and AR kind of the next smartphone, right, or the next platform. And there's a huge amount of potential here, and it's already being used by tons of people. And so we're going to try and learn as much as we can. And we have Conal here, who is the CTO of Zapar. And yeah, thanks a lot for coming on the show, Conal.
大家好，我们今天有一期非常棒的节目。我想很多人都尝试过虚拟现实（VR），甚至尝试过增强现实（AR），只是可能不知道它们的名字。我们在录音前刚聊到这个话题。所以我们今天将深入探讨这个功能。我认为很多人把VR和AR称为下一个智能手机，或者说下一个平台。这里蕴藏着巨大的潜力，而且已经有很多人在使用它了。所以我们尽量多了解一些。今天我们请到了Zapar的首席技术官Conal。Conal，非常感谢你来到我们的节目。
Thanks for having me. It's a pleasure. Cool, cool. How are you doing? How are you making do with these crazy circumstances? Yeah, not bad. We're based in London, and so we had a big lockdown earlier on in the year. And during that process we of course as a business moved to complete working from home and I've actually just taken the decision to continue to have a completely flexible working scenario for people so some of us will be going back to
谢谢邀请，很高兴能来。太棒了。你最近怎么样？在这种疯狂的情况下，你过得还好吗？还不错。我们的总部在伦敦，所以今年早些时候我们经历了一次大规模的封锁。在这个过程中，我们公司当然全面转向了居家办公。我实际上刚刚决定，继续为员工提供完全灵活的工作模式，所以我们中的一些人会选择回到
the office who choose to do so and some of us will be working remotely for the foreseeable so yeah it's been interesting. But, you know, we've not really suffered any loss in productivity as a result, which has been great. And it's obviously not the case for everybody, which is unfortunate. Yeah, that makes sense. So as a company that is centered around augmented reality, were you able to, you know, with this kind of new environment,
办公室，而另一些人将在可预见的未来继续远程办公。所以，是的，这很有趣。但你知道，我们的生产力并没有因此受到任何损失，这很棒。当然，并不是每个人都这样，这很不幸。是的，这很有道理。那么，作为一家以增强现实为核心的公司，在这种新环境下，你们是否能够
like find a new product or were you able to sort of see some area that has been underserved by augmented reality since so many things now have to be done virtually? I think so. But I would say that they're not necessarily sectors that we hadn't seen before, but more that are growing faster as a result. So to take one example, product visualization in the home, augmented reality is a tool you can use to enhance product visualization in the home. And obviously, if people can't be going to stores to see and touch products in real life, then businesses are looking to see how they can help users experience what those
找到新的产品，或者说，由于现在很多事情必须在虚拟环境中完成，你们是否发现了一些被增强现实所忽视的领域？我想是的。但我认为这些领域并不一定是我们以前没见过的，更多的是因为这种情况而发展得更快。举个例子，家居产品可视化，增强现实是一个可以用来增强家居产品可视化的工具。显然，如果人们不能去商店亲眼看到和触摸产品，那么企业就会寻求帮助用户体验这些
products would be like. And you don't get all the way with something like AR or indeed with VR, but you get better than just seeing it on a page on your phone, for example. So there's a class of things like that. There are specific niche use cases which are kind of interesting. So one of the mechanisms for augmented reality which people might have tried before is face tracking so that's when you take content um and apply it to a user's face in a camera view so you might have tried face filters in snapchat for example
产品会是什么样子。虽然AR或VR并不能完全替代实物，但它比仅仅在手机页面上查看要好得多。所以这类事物有很多。还有一些特定的利基用例也很有趣。例如，人们可能以前尝试过的一种增强现实机制是面部追踪，也就是当你获取内容并将其应用到相机视图中的用户脸上时。比如你可能尝试过Snapchat的面部滤镜，
an example of this where you you put some 3d model around the face or head or you'll distort the head in some way um how to fit a mask properly, for example, is a use case where face tracking helps with that. You know, you can show users on their own face that the mask should cover their nose as well as below their mouth and how it should be attached around behind their ears and what have you. So there have been some interesting niche-specific use cases like that. But I'd say that on the whole, augmented reality as an industry has so many sectors, so many use cases that in some sectors that will have been affected by an economic downturn, and in other places there'll be opportunities. So a mixed bag, as is I'm sure the case with lots of industries at the moment. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I remember reading something which said
这就是一个例子，你在脸部或头部周围放置一些3D模型，或者以某种方式扭曲头部。例如，如何正确佩戴口罩就是一个面部追踪可以提供帮助的用例。你可以向用户展示口罩应该覆盖他们的鼻子以及嘴巴下方，以及它应该如何固定在耳朵后面等等。所以确实有一些有趣的利基特定用例。但我认为总的来说，增强现实作为一个行业，拥有如此多的领域和用例，在某些受经济衰退影响的行业中，在其他地方也会有新的机会。所以这是一个混合的情况，我相信目前许多行业都是如此。是的，这完全说得通。我记得读过一些东西，上面说
exactly what you said, which is the coronavirus situation kind of accelerated trends that they were expecting to take 10 years. We're accelerating them so that they happen in 10 weeks. I know personally, I started buying all my clothes online, which is something I'd never really done in the past. And yeah, I think I think a lot of people are kind of changing. And you're starting to realize the like latent advantages. Like one of the advantages I found is, you know, I mean, Patrick and I are both kind of like tall, lanky people. And so I like to buy especially shirts that are
和你刚才说的一模一样，即新冠疫情加速了那些原本预计需要10年才能实现的趋势。我们正在加速它们，让它们在10周内发生。我个人深有体会，我开始在网上购买所有的衣服，这在过去我从未真正做过。是的，我认为很多人都在改变。你开始意识到潜在的优势。比如我发现的一个优势是，我和Patrick都是那种又高又瘦的人。所以我喜欢买那种
medium tall, which is a very rare size. And now that I'm online, I can always get, you know, get that size and any style. And so that almost kind of trumps being able to try it on in the store because because you get the fit you want. And so, yeah, I think a lot of these trends, it's really going to be interesting when this is all over, like what remains, like what will be popular. Yeah, I was having a similar discussion with one of my colleagues the other day in terms of looking at things that have been huge changes in our history. And, you know, the things like 9-11, which obviously changed how we travel by air, for example, and, you know, mindsets and attitudes in lots of ways. It seems to me like this sort of thing will just eclipse something like 9-11 in terms of the ongoing changes it has for our society. So it's going to be super
中码加长款的衬衫，这是一种非常罕见的尺码。现在我在网上购物，总是能买到那个尺码和任何款式。这几乎胜过了在店里试穿，因为你能得到你想要的合身感。所以，是的，我认为很多这些趋势，当这一切结束时，看看什么会留下来，什么会流行起来，真的会很有趣。是的，前几天我和一位同事也进行了类似的讨论，回顾历史上那些巨大的变革。你知道，像9-11事件，它显然改变了我们的航空旅行方式，以及在许多方面的思维方式和态度。在我看来，这种事情在对我们社会产生的持续影响方面，甚至会超过9-11事件。所以，看看未来五年在工作和生活方面会发生什么，将是超级
fascinating to see what happens in the next like five years when it comes to working and being yeah and i i think that that you know dovetailing back you know i think i think ar and vr are probably like one of the areas that are going to really explode because of this um like actually just tying these two examples i mean it'd be awesome if i could actually see what that shirt looked like on me um before i bought it right and that's something you know, isn't available at at least any of the stores that I checked out online. Yeah, absolutely. Even just being able to see the physical size of something in your environment, even if it's, you know, not quite exactly the right 3D rendering to make it look exactly like your shirt really would, just being able to see, you know, either on a table next to a real one of your shirts oh that's
令人着迷的。而且我认为，回到刚才的话题，我认为AR和VR很可能是因为这个原因而真正爆发的领域之一。实际上，把这两个例子联系起来，如果我在购买之前能真正看到那件衬衫穿在我身上的样子，那该多好啊。这在至少我查看过的任何在线商店中都是不可用的。是的，绝对是。即使只是能够看到物体在你的环境中的物理尺寸，即使它不是完全精确的3D渲染，无法让你看到衬衫穿在身上的真实效果，但仅仅能够看到它放在你真实衬衫旁边的桌子上，哦，原来
how it compares size wise it's very valuable yeah it's a good idea yeah totally yeah cool awesome interesting ways yeah so so why don't we explain um you know people have heard the term vr uh probably a lot of people have even heard the term ar but why don't you talk a little bit about, you know, what does virtual reality actually mean? And what is the difference between that and augmented reality? Sure. So virtual reality is a class of technologies that replace the environment that you're in as you experience it. So an example of that would be where you put a headset on, and that headset has a screen in front of your eyes. And as you look around your room, you experience a different environment. So it might be a planet far away or it might be a shopping environment or, you know, it could be anything.
它的大小是这样的，这非常有价值。是的，这是个好主意。完全同意。太酷了，很有趣。那么，我们来解释一下，人们可能听过VR这个词，可能很多人甚至听过AR这个词，但你能不能谈谈，虚拟现实到底是什么意思？它和增强现实有什么区别？当然。虚拟现实是一类技术，它在你体验时会替换掉你所处的环境。一个例子就是你戴上头显，头显里有一个屏幕在你眼前。当你环顾房间时，你体验到的是一个不同的环境。它可能是一个遥远的星球，或者是一个购物环境，或者，你知道，它可以是任何东西。
The point, I suppose, with virtual reality is it's just not the one that you're actually in. It's some virtual content um so a classic sci-fi example the holodeck in star trek is a you're almost idealized virtual reality environment where people can walk around and it's almost like they're actually at the place that's being represented yeah yeah augmented reality uh is halfway between virtual reality and our real world environment what augmented reality does is it starts with the room that you're currently in or or you're um in the case the case of face tracking as we discussed it starts with a camera view of your actual real face and then it takes virtual content and adds that into that environment
我想虚拟现实的重点在于，它不是你实际所处的环境。它是一些虚拟内容。一个经典的科幻例子是《星际迷航》中的全息甲板，那是一个近乎理想化的虚拟现实环境，人们可以在里面走动，感觉就像他们真的身处那个被呈现的地方。是的，是的。增强现实是介于虚拟现实和我们真实世界环境之间的一种技术。增强现实所做的是，它从你当前所在的房间开始，或者在面部追踪的情况下，它从你真实面部的相机视图开始，然后它获取虚拟内容并将其添加到该环境中，
as if it's actually there present with you and so so, as I say, that could be, you know, a hat on your head that you're previewing with a face filter experience to see what it might look like. It could be pointing at your living room and seeing a virtual chair in that space in order to see what it would look like, where it's actually be in your room. We can also track things. So I should explain, I suppose, tracking is the process of working out where something is in your environment in order to be able to attach content to it. So face tracking, it's an algorithm that finds where in a camera image your face is
就好像它真的存在于你身边一样。所以，正如我所说，这可能是一个你通过面部滤镜体验预览的帽子，看看它戴在头上是什么样子。它可能是指向你的客厅，在那个空间里看到一把虚拟椅子，以便看看它放在你房间里会是什么样子。我们还可以追踪物体。所以我应该解释一下，追踪是确定物体在环境中位置的过程，以便能够将内容附加到它上面。所以面部追踪，它是一种在相机图像中找到你脸部位置的算法，
so that then when you come to put 3D content on top of it, you know exactly where it should be to line it up on the screen. And so you can track things like faces, you can track things like surfaces or the environment around you, and you can track images and other things. For example, people might have used Connect, Microsoft Connect. It's this camera you could get for Xbox.
这样当你把3D内容放在上面时，你就知道它应该在屏幕上的什么位置来对齐。所以你可以追踪像脸部这样的东西，你可以追踪像表面或你周围环境这样的东西，你还可以追踪图像和其他东西。例如，人们可能使用过Kinect，微软的Kinect。这是你可以为Xbox购买的摄像头。
And if you stood in front of the camera, the Xbox would be able to know where your arms and legs are in the world. And so there would be gameplay experiences where you move your arms in order to move your character in the game. And so that would be a body tracker or a skeleton tracker, if you like.
如果你站在摄像头前，Xbox就能知道你的手臂和腿在世界上的位置。所以会有一些游戏体验，你需要移动手臂来控制游戏中的角色。所以那是一个身体追踪器，或者如果你愿意的话，叫骨骼追踪器。
And so augmented reality is a huge class of these types of technologies, and there's lots of different ways it's implemented. But that core principle is it's your environment, but some additional virtual content is added. Cool, that makes sense. And so I think virtual reality is, there are definitely some, let's say let's say black magic or something that
所以增强现实是这类技术的一个巨大类别，实现方式有很多种。但核心原则是，它是你的环境，但添加了一些额外的虚拟内容。太酷了，这很有道理。我认为虚拟现实，肯定有一些，比如说黑魔法之类的东西，
requires definitely expertise to understand how, you know, when you turn your head, how it sort of knows, but you can kind of intuit it from things like cell phones where, you know, there's clearly a compass. And if you're on, you know, Google Maps or Apple Maps and you turn the phone, the point on the blue dot, you know, attached to the blue dot turns, right? And so it's more intuitive. Augmented reality is the one that seems like just totally black magic. Like, how does it take this picture and realize that there is this surface that's going in this direction, you know, a table that you can put something on? How does it distinguish that from the wall?
确实需要专业知识才能理解，你知道，当你转头时，它是如何知道的。但你可以从手机等设备中直观地感受到，那里显然有一个指南针。如果你在谷歌地图或苹果地图上，当你转动手机时，蓝点上的指针也会跟着转，对吧？所以它更直观。增强现实看起来才完全是黑魔法。它是如何拍摄这张照片并意识到有一个朝这个方向延伸的表面，比如你可以放东西的桌子？它是如何将其与墙壁区分开来的？
I think that is something that really just blows people's mind. And, yeah, what would be, you know, your answer to somebody who asks, like, just how can something like that work? That's a really good question. And I should say our CEO at Zapper, Casper, he is a fantastic guy, but by his own admission, he's not like super tech. He's definitely tech savvy, but he's not a programmer or anything like that. I had exactly this conversation with him where we've tried to say like uh how how does it go from being like pixels on a screen to being an experience that understands the world you're in and i suppose underlying this it's the same with lots of other really complex systems where if you actually break it down into
我认为这确实让人们感到震惊。那么，对于问“这种东西到底是怎么工作的”的人，你的回答会是什么？这是一个非常好的问题。我应该说，我们在Zapper的首席执行官Casper，他是一个很棒的人，但他自己承认，他不是那种超级技术型的人。他绝对懂技术，但他不是程序员之类的。我和他进行过完全一样的对话，我们试图说，它是如何从屏幕上的像素变成一个理解你所处环境的体验的？我想这背后的道理和许多其他非常复杂的系统一样，如果你把它分解成
a kind of pipeline of of constituent parts where each each part in that pipeline is kind of more easily understandable then together when you build it all together you end up with something that that seems like more than the sum of its parts um so i can give you an example for some of those parts in an ar circumstance uh so the very first lowest level we have for example a stream of camera frames coming from a camera on a mobile phone and so that's just like a stream of camera frames coming from a camera on a mobile phone. And so that's just like a stream of image files that you might get on your computer, like PNGs or JPEGs. At the end of the day, it's a file of data where each little bit of that file is a pixel on the screen of that or in the center of that camera, if you like. And so the very first stage in an AR process is to take that stream.
一系列组成部分，其中每个部分都更容易理解，那么当你把它们组合在一起时，你最终会得到一个看起来比各部分之和更强大的东西。所以我可以给你举一个AR环境下的例子。在最底层，我们有来自手机摄像头的相机帧流。这就像你电脑上可能得到的图像文件流，比如PNG或JPEG。归根结底，它是一个数据文件，其中文件的每一小部分都是屏幕上的一个像素，或者如果你愿意的话，是相机中心的一个像素。所以AR过程的第一阶段是获取那个流。
And I should say different algorithms for different types of tracking work in different ways. But let's say that we want to track the surface of our table. What the first thing that will happen in lots of these algorithms is it will take that all of those pixels and reduce the amount of data that's involved there into a much smaller set of data but with that data has a bit more meaning so the first thing you might do is look for corners in the image or areas that are high contrast little features in the image and it's the sort of thing that your eye would be drawn to if you were looking at a table so there might be a knot in the wood in the table or there might just be kind of grains in the wood. Or if it's a marble table, there would be marbling, you know, just little bits of interesting visual content in that image.
我应该说，不同类型的追踪算法工作方式不同。但假设我们想追踪桌子的表面。在许多这些算法中，首先发生的事情是它会获取所有这些像素，并将其中涉及的数据量减少到一个更小的数据集，但这些数据具有更多的含义。所以你可能做的第一件事是寻找图像中的角点或高对比度区域，即图像中的小特征。如果你在看一张桌子，这正是你的眼睛会被吸引到的地方。所以桌子上可能有一个木结，或者可能只是木头里的纹理。或者如果是大理石桌子，会有大理石花纹，你知道，图像中只有一点点有趣的视觉内容。
And so we have algorithms that can look through the pixels and say, you know, this little group has more high contrast pixels than other areas. And with some clever choice of how we define those elements, we end up with being able to say, you know, at this point in the image, there's something interesting. At this point in the image, there's something interesting. And indeed, if we look between the frames, those are relatively consistent. So that the grain of, or the knot in the wood in this frame versus the knot of wood in the next frame
所以我们有算法可以查看像素并说，你知道，这个小区域比其他区域有更多的高对比度像素。通过巧妙地选择我们如何定义这些元素，我们最终能够说，在图像的这一点上，有一些有趣的东西。在图像的这一点上，有一些有趣的东西。而且确实，如果我们观察帧与帧之间，这些是相对一致的。所以这一帧中的木纹或木结与下一帧中的木结
looks sufficiently similar that between those frames, when we're calculating what's going on, we can say that particular place in the image has moved from there to there between these frames. And then what you typically do in the next stage up is you take a ton of these matches or correspondences between these frames and you do some effectively geometry to work out if that was there in the last frame and that was there in that frame and it's now here and that one's now here. What has the camera done? How has the camera moved in order to make sure that those places all match up between the two
看起来足够相似，以至于在这些帧之间，当我们计算发生了什么时，我们可以说图像中的那个特定位置在这些帧之间从那里移动到了那里。然后你通常在下一阶段所做的是，你获取大量的这些匹配或帧之间的对应关系，并进行一些有效的几何计算，以算出如果它在上一帧中在那里，而在那一帧中在那里，现在它在这里，那个现在在那里。相机做了什么？相机是如何移动的，以确保这些位置在两个
different frames. And then the complexity is just from there, you know, how you work that mass out, you end up with a set of maths that matches very similar to what you get when you're like rendering 3D content in a computer game. And so we have matrix math or linear algebra. If you studied that at school or university, we end up with matrices that represent the movement of objects and cameras. And those are exactly the sorts of math that we use then to say, now take this 3D model and position it into this scene as if the camera had moved between these frames from here to here. So the idea is like if you have a single picture with a knot in a table,
不同的帧之间都能匹配上。然后复杂性就从那里开始了，你知道，你如何算出那个数学结果，你最终会得到一套数学公式，这与你在电脑游戏中渲染3D内容时得到的非常相似。所以我们有矩阵数学或线性代数。如果你在学校或大学学习过，我们最终会得到代表物体和相机运动的矩阵。这些正是我们随后使用的数学方法，用来表示：现在获取这个3D模型并将其定位到这个场景中，就好像相机在这些帧之间从这里移动到了这里。所以这个想法就像如果你有一张带有桌子木结的单张照片，
then there's kind of like a cone coming out of your eye or out of the eye of the camera, and the knot can really be anywhere in that cone. I mean, the knot could be, you know, hundreds and hundreds of feet away if this is some gigantic table, maybe you're at a table conference or something. But, you know, it's somewhere in that cone. And then if you were to move your head, or if you were to, you know, close one eye and open the other eye, if you were to move your head or if you were to you know close one eye and open the other eye if you had stereo vision right but you can kind of accomplish this by moving as well now you have this second cone that sees the knot and so the knot actually exists you know at the intersection of those two cones and so you're kind of doing this over and over again yeah exactly and sometimes um sometimes if you know enough about your environment, you can work things out without having to track things a single frame of a video be able to say, you know, that that image is here and it's positioned and rotated in this way in the camera frame.
那么从你的眼睛或相机眼睛里会有一个圆锥体出来，木结确实可以在那个圆锥体里的任何地方。我的意思是，木结可能在几百英尺远的地方，如果这是一张巨大的桌子，也许你在参加一个桌子会议之类的。但是，你知道，它在那个圆锥体里的某个地方。然后如果你移动你的头，或者如果你，你知道，闭上一只眼睛打开另一只眼睛，如果你移动你的头，或者如果你闭上一只眼睛打开另一只眼睛，如果你有立体视觉，对吧？但你也可以通过移动来实现这一点。现在你有第二个圆锥体看到了木结，所以木结实际上存在于那两个圆锥体的交点处。所以你是在一遍又一遍地做这个。是的，完全正确。有时，如果你对你的环境了解得足够多，你可以在不需要追踪视频单帧的情况下算出事情，能够说，你知道，那个图像在这里，并且在相机帧中以这种方式定位和旋转。
But most of the time we use the fact that we have multiple frames coming in from the camera over time to to track an object smoothly in the camera. And I should say that these technologies are the types of technologies that were used in computer generated graphics for movies. You know, when you have the T-Rex in Jurassic Park running along behind your truck, the computation and the processing that the computer, the visual graphics and effects people do is a kind of similar thing for working out the environment, working out the motion of cameras between frames in order to then apply the same, but other way around motion to the dinosaur so that it moves in the frame in the correct way. The difference with modern augmented reality that people might use is that we just have to be able to do that processing very quickly. So it has to be 30 frames every second in order to get smooth video that would come from a
但大多数时候，我们利用我们随着时间从相机获取多个帧的事实，来平滑地追踪相机中的物体。我应该说，这些技术是用于电影计算机生成图形的那类技术。你知道，当《侏罗纪公园》里的霸王龙在你的卡车后面奔跑时，计算机视觉图形和特效人员所做的计算和处理，与为了理解环境、计算帧与帧之间相机的运动，以便随后将相同但反向的运动应用到恐龙身上，使其在帧中以正确方式移动，是类似的事情。现代增强现实与人们可能使用的技术的区别在于，我们必须能够非常快地进行处理。所以它必须是每秒30帧，才能获得来自
camera image and in some cases if you if you're wearing headsets for example you actually want 60 frames per second if you can you know actually quite a lot and high uh high speed computation has to happen in order to make that work cool Cool. That makes sense. So I think, okay, so we have these points. So we've discovered, you know, here's the corner of the table. Here's some knots in the wood. Here's some marks on the wall that we can track, right? And we're able to do that in real time, which that by itself sounds really, really hard. I have to admit, I don't know how that actually happens. That's pretty remarkable. So then how do we go from that to some 3D geometry to say that this is a surface that has a normal in this direction and so we could put a shirt on it?
相机图像的平滑视频。在某些情况下，如果你戴着头显，你实际上需要每秒60帧，如果你能做到的话，你知道，实际上相当多。为了使之工作，必须进行高速计算。太酷了。这很有道理。所以我想，好的，我们有这些点。所以我们发现了，这里是桌子的角。这里是木头里的一些木结。这里是墙上我们可以追踪的一些标记，对吧？而且我们能够实时做到这一点，这本身听起来就非常非常难。我必须承认，我不知道这是怎么发生的。这非常了不起。那么我们是如何从这一点过渡到一些3D几何图形，来说明这是一个朝这个方向有法线的表面，所以我们可以把一件衬衫放在上面？
We wouldn't want to put a shirt on the wall, for example. Yeah. Well, so the answer is there's different ways that you can do that. Some of that, so surface detection, for example, with surface detection, if you want to say, like, the table is flat in front of you, normally you would also supplement this algorithm with things like gyroscope data or accelerometer data
我们不会想把衬衫放在墙上，例如。是的。嗯，所以答案是有不同的方法可以做到这一点。其中一些，比如表面检测，例如，通过表面检测，如果你想说，比如，桌子在你面前是平的，通常你也会用陀螺仪数据或加速度计数据来补充这个算法，
from your device. So in modern smartphones, they have a very good gyroscope so that the phone can tell very well when small rotations of the device happen. So it can know, oh, the user's turned the device a few degrees this way. They also have not normally quite as good a sensor, but still good enough to kind of get things started, an accelerometer, which knows which way gravity is. So it knows relative to where you're holding the device, gravity is in that direction. And then a combination of that sensor,
来自你的设备。所以现代智能手机有一个非常好的陀螺仪，这样手机就能很好地判断设备何时发生微小的旋转。所以它可以知道，哦，用户把设备往这边转了几度。它们通常还有一个传感器，虽然通常没那么好，但仍然足以开始工作，即加速度计，它知道重力在哪里。所以它知道相对于你拿着设备的地方，重力在那个方向。然后结合那个传感器，
a combination of the gyroscope knowing, oh, well, you've now moved the device by this number of degrees from that gravity position that we understood. And you add that into the images that we're getting from the camera. You can build, we call this sensor fusion. So you take all of these sensory inputs, including the camera, and you fuse them together to build up an understanding of that environment. But the process of doing surface detection, so knowing that your table is in front of you and what height it's at and
结合陀螺仪知道，哦，你现在已经把设备从我们理解的那个重力位置移动了这么多度。然后你把它加到我们从相机得到的图像中。你可以构建，我们称之为传感器融合。所以你获取所有这些传感器输入，包括相机，并将它们融合在一起，以建立对该环境的理解。但是表面检测的过程，即知道桌子在你面前，它在什么高度，以及
the, you know, the extents of the table, so how far it goes in each direction, that's quite a complex process that is, you know, a lot of research time, I suppose, has gone into how you solve that problem, especially how you do it real time. Yeah, I mean, that sounds that sounds insanely difficult. I don't know how I have no idea how that works. But yeah, I mean, that's it's definitely so it's called surface detection. And so that's that's that process that takes these set of key points and maybe the raw images as well, and then figures out sort of a set of I guess it's sort of some kind of segmentation and then figures out for each of set of, I guess it's sort of some kind of segmentation
你知道，桌子的范围，即它在每个方向延伸多远，这是一个相当复杂的过程，你知道，我想很多研究时间都花在了如何解决这个问题上，特别是如何实时解决它。是的，我的意思是，这听起来听起来极其困难。我不知道我完全不知道它是怎么工作的。但是的，我的意思是，这绝对所以它被称为表面检测。所以这就是那个过程，它获取这些关键点集，也许还有原始图像，然后算出，我想这是一种分割，然后算出每一组，我想这是一种分割
and then figures out for each of those segments which way it's actually facing. Yeah, and lots of the time you don't actually need to know very much about the surface. You can be surprised, I suppose, about how much you can get away with just being able to track a single point in your camera image and then knowing, for example, which way up is in your world. That makes sense. Yeah. Yeah. So if you're happy to be having an experience that takes place on your floor, so on a surface that's not going to move in your environment or on a static table, then being able to track a single point and know which way up is, you can actually do quite a lot of interesting experiences with that sort of thing.
然后算出这些片段中的每一个实际上是朝向哪里的。是的，很多时候你实际上不需要知道关于表面的太多信息。我想你会惊讶于仅仅能够追踪相机图像中的一个点，然后知道，例如，你的世界里哪边是上方，你就能做多少事情。这很有道理。是的。是的。所以如果你乐于进行一种发生在你的地板上的体验，即在一个在你的环境中不会移动的表面上，或者在一个静态的桌子上，那么能够追踪一个点并知道哪边是上方，你实际上可以用那种东西做很多有趣的体验。
Yeah, that makes a ton of sense, right? Because I mean, most of the things you're interested in are at 90 degrees. Like you're interested in walls, tables, floors, and so you don't have to consider all the possibilities there. Yeah, exactly. And, you know, lots of the time, technology like that we have at Zapper will be used for a creative experience where you might have a character appear and be talking to you, or maybe it's a virtual tennis player and you can play some tennis with them. You don't really need to be understanding too much really about the environment that the user is in in order to facilitate that. That said, there are a ton of use cases where actually knowing that, you know, what the actual surfaces are, where the walls are, et cetera,
是的，这非常有道理，对吧？因为我的意思是，你感兴趣的大多数东西都是90度的。比如你对墙壁、桌子、地板感兴趣，所以你不必考虑那里的所有可能性。是的，完全正确。而且，你知道，很多时候，像我们在Zapper拥有的那种技术将被用于创意体验，你可能会有一个角色出现并和你说话，或者也许是一个虚拟网球运动员，你可以和他们打网球。你真的不需要太了解用户所处的环境来促进这一点。话虽如此，有大量的用例实际上知道，你知道，实际表面是什么，墙壁在哪里等等，
that facilitates quite a lot of applications that you can't otherwise do. It's just the more you want to understand about the environment, the more computationally difficult it becomes to work it out. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, and devices like the iPhone, for example, have machine learning chips in them specifically to try and process data a lot faster to be able to run in the much more limited computational environment that your web browser is. So in that sort of circumstance, we have a different set of appropriate applications that we can support based on the type of computations we can do. Yeah, that makes sense. And one thing I want to point folks to, if they missed episode 102 with Max Sklar, we talked about Bayesian mathematics and dealing with uncertainty.
这促进了相当多的应用程序，否则你无法做到。只是你越想了解环境，计算上就越难算出它。是的，这很有道理。是的，像iPhone这样的设备，有专门的机器学习芯片，试图更快地处理数据，以便能够在你的网络浏览器这种计算环境非常有限的情况下运行。所以在那种情况下，我们根据我们可以做的计算类型，有不同的一套适当的应用程序可以支持。是的，这很有道理。我想向大家指出一件事，如果他们错过了第102集与Max Sklar的对话，我们谈到了贝叶斯数学和处理不确定性。
And this is a perfect example of that, where you have an accelerometer, it has error. You have a gyroscope with error and you have these images and that algorithm, there's like irreducible error. I mean, there are things that are just ambiguous and there's also error in the algorithm itself, right? And so the way you kind of deal with all of that is you just kind of put all of that uncertainty into this fusion system and it kind of reconciles that. So if your accelerometer is very unhappy, I don't actually know very much about mechanical things, but let's assume you dropped your phone and that made your accelerometer unhappy
这是一个完美的例子，你有加速度计，它有误差。你有带误差的陀螺仪，你有这些图像和那个算法，有不可约的误差。我的意思是，有些事情只是模棱两可的，算法本身也有误差，对吧？所以你处理所有这些的方法就是你只是把所有的不确定性放入这个融合系统中，它会以某种方式调和它。所以如果你的加速度计非常不开心，我实际上对机械的东西了解不多，但假设你摔了手机，这让你的加速度计不开心了
for a few minutes or something, the system would understand that and it would compensate with the other devices, right? Or if you were in a very flat room, then maybe that could be compensated by the hardware on your phone. And it all kind of works together in harmony. That's exactly right. And those exact techniques that you're talking about, modeling the error, trying to work out how certain you can be about some
几分钟之类的，系统会理解这一点，它会用其他设备进行补偿，对吧？或者如果你在一个非常平坦的房间里，那么这可能可以通过手机上的硬件来补偿。它们都以某种方式和谐地工作在一起。完全正确。而且你谈论的那些确切的技术，建模误差，试图算出你对某种
sort of truth in the environment that you're trying to understand versus the sensor input you're getting. We also have a different lag between things like sensors and cameras. So we might, for example, get very high resolution and very fast data back from the gyroscope. I also am not very mechanically minded, so I have no idea why gyroscopes are better than accelerometers. But gyroscopes seem to be really good. Actually, just an aside, I remember reading something, and people should check this out, but the way the gyroscope works in such a small device is it's like an extremely tiny ball. And in that hollow ball, there's some kind of fluid and another ball. And in that hollow ball, there's like some kind of fluid and another ball.
你试图理解的环境中的真相有多确定，相对于你得到的传感器输入。我们还在传感器和相机等事物之间有不同的延迟。所以我们可能，例如，从陀螺仪获得非常高分辨率和非常快的数据。我也不是很有机械头脑，所以我不知道为什么陀螺仪比加速度计好。但陀螺仪似乎真的很好。实际上，只是顺便提一下，我记得读过一些东西，人们应该去看看，但在这样的小设备中陀螺仪的工作方式就像一个极小的球。在那个空心球里，有一些液体和另一个球。在那个空心球里，有一些液体和另一个球。
And basically where those two balls contact is how it determines. But it's like macroscopic or microscopic. And it's unbelievable. You should see, you know, you could do a Google search or something and see how the gyroscope in your phone, like what it actually looks like. It's remarkable. I find it fascinating to think about like all of the tech that sits in these devices in our pockets. And, you know, I think if when, you know, we're at the gates of heaven and we were to be shown exactly the complexity
基本上那两个球接触的地方就是它确定的方式。但它是宏观的还是微观的。这令人难以置信。你应该看看，你知道，你可以做一个谷歌搜索之类的，看看你手机里的陀螺仪，它实际上看起来是什么样子的。这很了不起。我觉得思考我们口袋里这些设备中的所有技术非常迷人。而且，你知道，我想如果当，你知道，我们在天堂之门，我们被展示了手机内部的
inside the phone in some sort of moment of enlightenment, I think it would be incredibly mind-blowing yeah it would be like taking uh george washington and putting him in a time machine and putting him in in time square or something right i mean it would just blow our mind uh you know and and it's the encapsulation is incredible right that it's it's uh we've taken all of this complexity but we've been able to provide value to just about everybody. Indeed. And I think there's a kind of a comfort in how broad we have been able to use computing, I suppose, as a race, because if you were to take George Washington and bring him to now and then like show him show him some cat video from from reddit he might be like what why why are we using the technology like this um yeah it's so true but the comfort comes in being able to say you know it's exactly this set of technologies that also
确切复杂性，在某种顿悟时刻，我认为这会非常令人震惊。是的，这就像把乔治·华盛顿带到时间机器里，把他放在时代广场之类的，对吧？我的意思是，这会让我们大吃一惊。你知道，而且封装是不可思议的，对吧？我们已经获取了所有这些复杂性，但我们已经能够为几乎每个人提供价值。确实。而且我认为我们能够使用计算的广泛程度有一种安慰，我想，作为一个种族，因为如果你把乔治·华盛顿带到现代，然后给他看一些来自Reddit的猫咪视频，他可能会说，为什么我们为什么要这样使用技术？嗯，是的，这太真实了，但安慰来自于能够说，你知道，正是这套技术也
facilitates like a surgeon across the world being able to to perform surgery on on somebody in an in a hospital without the same facilities um you know it in that case it probably still comes down to like mpeg encoding a video and so you know there's there's for every flippant use there's there's probably something that's doing a lot of good in the world. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. I mean, that was really well said. Yeah. I think, um, yeah, it's interesting. There's a lot of energy spent on, um, you know, how can we better use, uh, free time, but then almost serendipitously, we end up, we end up, uh, making better use of people's work time. I mean, what I'm thinking in my mind is the Google Glass, which was an originally represented as a, you know, B2C, business to consumer kind of product
促进了像世界各地的外科医生能够在没有相同设施的医院里为某人进行手术，你知道，在这种情况下，它可能仍然归结为像MPEG编码视频，所以你知道，对于每一个轻率的用途，可能都有一些正在世界上做很多好事的事情。是的，绝对是。是的。我的意思是，那说得真好。是的。我想，嗯，是的，这很有趣。有很多精力花在，嗯，你知道，我们如何更好地利用，嗯，空闲时间，但随后几乎是偶然地，我们最终，我们最终，嗯，更好地利用了人们的工作时间。我的意思是，我脑子里想到的是谷歌眼镜，它最初被呈现为一种，你知道，B2C，企业对消费者那种产品
where people would use it, you know, in their free time or maybe as part of their daily activity. But then what ended up happening with Google Glass is the physician, the medical community picked it up. And so, you know, my dermatologist I've been going to for years and years, she's been using this Google Glass for years and as part of her daily routine. And so, yeah, as you said, I mean, it's amazing how you build things, really just entertain yourself. And then in that serendipity comes, you know, real amazing progress that can change a whole industry.
人们会在他们的空闲时间使用它，或者也许作为他们日常活动的一部分。但后来谷歌眼镜发生的事情是，医生，医疗界选择了它。所以，你知道，我看了多年的皮肤科医生，她多年来一直使用这种谷歌眼镜，作为她日常工作的一部分。所以，是的，正如你所说，我的意思是，你构建东西的方式很神奇，真的只是为了娱乐自己。然后在那种偶然中，你知道，真正的惊人进步可以改变整个行业。
Yeah, and I think augmented reality is a particular industry where this is such an important concept, because there are lots of uses of augmented reality out there, which are entertainment uses, that are marketing uses. So, for example, to take Snapchat face filters where, you know, users get what we would still call short-term but delightful value out of something. So, you know, a user's going to have a go at a Snapchat face filter, and in 10 minutes, they're not going to be using it, and probably will have forgotten about it in that time. But for the time that they were using it, they enjoyed the process of using it. They've had some interesting social interactions as a result. That process has probably been monetized by advertisers. So there's a value chain that goes elsewhere in the industry, I suppose, also. And it's easy to look at a use case like that and be cynical about it and say, you know, it's a short term entertainment experience.
是的，我认为增强现实是一个特别的行业，这是一个非常重要的概念，因为有很多增强现实的用途，它们是娱乐用途，是营销用途。例如，以Snapchat面部滤镜为例，你知道，用户从某些东西中获得了我们仍然称之为短期但令人愉快的价值。所以，你知道，用户会尝试Snapchat面部滤镜，在10分钟内，他们就不会再使用它了，而且可能在那时就已经忘记了它。但在他们使用它的时间里，他们享受了使用它的过程。他们因此进行了一些有趣的社交互动。那个过程可能已经被广告商货币化了。所以我想行业中还有其他地方的价值链。而且很容易看待像那样的用例并对此持怀疑态度，说，你知道，这是一种短期的娱乐体验。
But at the end of the day, it is delivering value for the user and for the, you know, the upward chain in that industry. And also those same technologies are powering other forms of technology elsewhere where it has a different set of value, a different kind of value mechanic. So because this technology is necessarily very content rich, there's just an interesting mix of different use cases where how, I don't want to use the word frivolous, but, you know, how short termterm an experience is for a user versus other
但归根结底，它正在为用户和行业中上游链条提供价值。而且同样的技术也在为其他形式的技术提供动力，在其他地方它有一套不同的价值，一种不同类型的价值机制。所以因为这项技术必然是非常内容丰富的，所以有不同用例的有趣组合，关于如何，我不想用轻浮这个词，但是，你知道，用户体验有多短，而其他
cases where it might be a lot longer term. But in general, it's all valid use. Yeah, and I think the smartphone followed the same trajectory. I think there was Palm Pilot and some of these things, but they didn't have contraction. What really took off was ultimately the iPod, right? So the iPod, which is a way for you to listen to
情况可能长期得多。但总的来说，这都是有效的用途。是的，而且我认为智能手机遵循了同样的轨迹。我想有Palm Pilot和其中一些东西，但它们没有收缩。最终起飞的是iPod，对吧？所以iPod，这是一种让你在公共汽车上听音乐的方式，或者其他什么，你知道，变得非常非常受欢迎。然后他们开始在iPod上放一个屏幕。有iPod touch。然后很明显人们想要Wi-Fi，因为他们不想通过网络共享来获取歌曲，对吧？然后如果你有Wi-Fi，那么不妨放上3G，对吧？所以这就像一些开始时，你知道，你可能会说，好吧，为什么不在你的笔记本电脑上听音乐呢？所以它开始时只是像这种奢侈配件，它变成了一种让世界各地的人们学习新东西的方式，对吧？
music on the bus or something, you know, became very, very popular. And then they started putting a screen on the iPod. There was the iPod touch. And then it was pretty obvious that people wanted Wi-Fi because they didn't want to you know get songs through tethering right and then if you have wi-fi then might as well put 3g right and so it's like something that started off as you know you might say well why not just have music on your laptop right so it started off as just kind of like this luxury accessory and it turned into a way for people all over the world to learn something new, right? Yeah, absolutely. I think that particular example is fascinating as well, because
是的，绝对是。我认为那个特定的例子也很迷人，因为
if you look at something like the Palm Pilots from the 90s, you can see already there, you know, the basis of all of these little bits of technology, you know, I'm sure Palm Pilots could play music or MP3s or maybe wav files back in the day and for it's easy for us to in hindsight look at that and say you know it's obvious that basically everybody's going to end up having one of these and it's going to replace their their telephone it's going to replace their music player their alarm clock their like note taking their voice recorder you know like you. The list is huge. And it seems obvious in retrospect.
如果你看看像90年代的Palm Pilots，你已经可以看到那里，你知道，所有这些小技术的基石，你知道，我相信Palm Pilots可以播放音乐或MP3或也许是wav文件，在过去，我们事后回顾并说，你知道，很明显基本上每个人最终都会拥有其中一个，而且它将取代他们的电话，它将取代他们的音乐播放器，他们的闹钟，他们的笔记记录，他们的录音机，你知道，像你。列表很长。而且回顾起来似乎很明显。
But I imagine, I suppose at the time, it just doesn't occur to people. And I think you have to make mistakes, too. And I always get this backwards, but there's the capacitive touchscreen and the resistive touchscreen. And one of them basically, the short story is one of them requires a pen. It's just not good enough for you to use your finger on. And so if you were to use like the Apple Newton or one of these Palm devices from the 90s, you'd have to use a stylus. But I don't know if you could have just invented
但我猜想，当时人们可能根本没往那方面想。而且我认为你必须得犯错。我总是把这两个概念搞混，一个是电容式触摸屏，一个是电阻式触摸屏。简单来说，其中一种需要用笔。用手指操作的效果并不理想。所以如果你用的是苹果的Newton或者90年代的Palm设备，你就必须用手写笔。但我不知道你是否能凭空发明出
the iPod Touch touchscreen. I think you had to take those stepping stones. Yeah, absolutely. And I wonder what the process at Apple was in terms of how many aha moments there were in the production of the iPod to be like, oh, you know, this is, there are so many use cases beyond what we're developing here. And eventually you end up with what are very ubiquitous general purpose computing devices that we all carry around in our pockets. Hey guys, I'm going to step in here. This episode actually has a new sponsor for us,
iPod Touch那样的触摸屏。我认为你必须一步一个脚印地走过来。是的，绝对是这样。我很好奇苹果内部的流程是怎样的，在iPod的生产过程中有多少个“顿悟时刻”，让他们意识到，哦，除了我们正在开发的这些功能，还有这么多其他的应用场景。最终，你得到了我们现在随身携带的、无处不在的通用计算设备。嘿，伙计们，我得插一句。这一集其实有一个新的赞助商，
and that is Teamistry. Teamistry sponsored this episode, and they're a podcast that talks about teams that work together, how teams operate, how you can operate in teams using stories from the past, stories from current events, and just really giving you helpful hints about how to be a good team player. Yeah, this is totally awesome. You know, we talk so much about soft skills. And we had an episode of soft skill about soft skills, you know, earlier with I think, john son was, but, you know, it's, it's hard to dedicate, you know, we can't dedicate this whole podcast to that. And so, you know, team history, that really complements ours. You know,
那就是Teamistry。Teamistry赞助了这一集，他们是一个讨论团队协作、团队运作方式，以及如何利用过去和时事中的故事来在团队中工作的播客，他们真的会给你提供很多关于如何成为一名优秀团队成员的实用建议。是的，这太棒了。你知道，我们谈论了很多关于软技能的话题。我们之前有一集关于软技能的节目，我想是John Son做的，但是，你知道，很难专门……我们不能把整个播客都用来讲这个。所以，Teamistry真的对我们的节目是一个很好的补充。你知道，
I think these skills are super important. If you want to, you know, talk about how to improve things on your team, or if you just want to hear a bunch of stories of different teams, you know, get practical lessons about how you can kind of take some of those stories and apply them to, you know, the kind of job that you do. I think there's a current season and there's a season two that's coming out. We were fortunate enough to get a sneak peek of the second season. So it's pretty exciting stuff coming up. Yeah. So some of the season two are out now. I guess we don't have seasons. We're just one giant season. Yeah, probably. We're on our what?
我认为这些技能非常重要。如果你想讨论如何改善团队中的事物，或者如果你只是想听听关于不同团队的故事，获取一些实用的经验，了解如何将这些故事应用到你自己的工作中，我觉得这很有用。目前好像有第一季，还有即将推出的第二季。我们有幸提前预览了第二季的内容。所以接下来的内容非常令人兴奋。是的。所以第二季的一些内容现在已经出来了。我想我们没有分季。我们只是一个巨大的长篇。是的，可能吧。我们现在是在第几……
Is a season an entire calendar year? Because I think its season is literally like a season. So we would be on our 20th season or something. Okay, I don't know about that. So this is our second season. I believe the first season had about eight episodes. The first couple are out in season two. So if you check them out you can you can see them now and the the first episode of the new
一季是一个完整的日历年吗？因为我觉得它的“季”字面意思就是季节。所以我们现在应该是在第20季左右了。好吧，我不知道是不是这样。所以这是我们的第二季。我相信第一季大约有八集。第二季的前几集已经出来了。所以如果你去看看，你现在就能看到它们，而且新的一季……
season season two is about uh watch factory seiko so i i think most people sort of know about seiko um if you know about watches they make all kinds of watches everyone often knows about the cheap watches they make the little quartz watches that are know, sell from a few dollars all the way up to, they actually make very high-end watch collector level watches that are, I don't want to say, lots of money. So being a watch enthusiast myself, I knew about their brand. And this talks about the story of how they set up inside of Seiko sort of two competing teams to do research and development. And they were each doing their own thing. And, you know, this strategy is not super surprising. It's actually employed by, you know, other people as well. But I think one of the things that the episode talked about that I thought was really
第二季的第一集是关于精工（Seiko）手表工厂的。我想大多数人都听说过精工，如果你了解手表，他们生产各种各样的手表。大家通常都知道他们生产的廉价手表，那些几美元的小石英表，一直到……他们其实也生产非常高端的、收藏家级别的手表，我不想说它们很贵。作为一名手表爱好者，我了解他们的品牌。这一集讲述了精工内部如何设立两个竞争团队进行研发的故事。他们各自做各自的事情。而且，你知道，这种策略并不令人惊讶。实际上，其他人也采用了这种策略。但我认为这一集里提到的有一点我觉得非常……
cool because the first time I heard what they were going to, you know, talk about, and it's like, oh, yeah, of course, it's easy to set teams up to compete but how do you prevent them from you know you know getting at each other and it ultimately being a net negative um and that actually was what they talked about which was how the seiko um organized these two teams as being part of the same family a little bit of a sibling rivalry i don't want to give away the sort of whole podcast um but talking about how they balanced the improvements they got from having parallel R&D efforts without having them be in conflict with each other. And then taking through how Seiko went from, basically, I mean,
酷，因为我第一次听到他们要谈论的内容时，我就想，哦，是的，当然，设立竞争团队很容易，但你如何防止他们互相拆台，最终导致负面影响呢？而这正是他们所讨论的内容，即精工是如何将这两个团队组织成同一个大家庭的一部分的，有点像兄弟间的竞争。我不想剧透整个播客，但他们谈到了如何在不产生冲突的情况下，平衡并行研发所带来的改进。然后讲述了精工是如何从……基本上，我的意思是，
they're responsible for making Japanese watchmaking a thing competing with the Swiss. So most people know about Swiss watches. I guess it's a little bit of a, we would call it a meme these days, but you know, switch watch keeping is the sort of pinnacle, but now actually several Japanese brands compete on that level.
他们是让日本制表业能够与瑞士制表业竞争的功臣。所以大多数人都知道瑞士手表。我想这在今天有点像是一个梗，但你知道，瑞士制表被认为是巅峰，但现在实际上有几个日本品牌在那个水平上竞争。
And Seiko was one of the ones who really drove that. And then when quartz movements came out, they sort of came into their own and almost destroyed the Swiss industry, but we'll go on forever. This is not a watch podcast. So we'll keep moving. Team History. Patrick is way into watches. Oh, yeah. OK. People who know me know this is not not surprising. But yeah, we're very thankful for Team History sponsorship. Definitely check it out. I think it's super critical, as Jason was saying,
而精工就是真正推动这一进程的品牌之一。然后当石英机芯出现时，他们迎来了自己的时代，几乎摧毁了瑞士工业，但我们会永远讲下去。这不是一个手表播客。所以我们要继续了。Teamistry。Patrick非常喜欢手表。哦，是的。好吧。了解我的人都知道这并不令人惊讶。但是的，我们非常感谢Teamistry的赞助。一定要去看看。我认为这非常关键，正如Jason所说，
for engineers to not forget about those soft skills. We like to focus on improving programming and being better at that. But whether you want to or not, politics and teamwork are crucial to becoming a well-rounded employee. And you can search for Teamistry anywhere you listen to podcasts. We're going to add a link in the show notes. Thanks to Teamistry for their support. And I'm going to turn it over back to the interview. So most people have seen the Oculus Rift and all of the things along those lines, so the HTC Vive. And so I'm sure people have sort of this mental image of the thing you put over your face. And now it's even wireless. I don't remember.
工程师们不要忘记那些软技能。我们喜欢专注于提高编程能力并做得更好。但无论你是否愿意，政治和团队合作对于成为一名全面发展的员工至关重要。你可以在任何收听播客的地方搜索Teamistry。我们会在节目说明中添加一个链接。感谢Teamistry的支持。现在我把话语权交回给采访。所以大多数人都见过Oculus Rift以及类似的产品，比如HTC Vive。所以我相信人们对戴在脸上的东西有一种心理图像。而且现在它甚至是无线的。我不记得了。
I forgot which is the one that's wireless. Oh don't remember there's there's uh i forgot which is the one that's wireless uh oh i think there's an oculus quest quest that's what it is thanks so now it's even wire so you can imagine you're just putting this headset on and going for a walk right um but when it comes to augmented reality you know i don't think people uh well first of all i don't even know really what's out there in terms of hardware but but uh but i don't know if people have a good mental model for what that actually looks like. Can you kind of walk us through, you know, what is augmented reality now? I think the example you brought up where you hold up the phone, that's definitely in everyone's hands. But, you know, what is sort of, is that the state of the art and what's, you know, coming in terms of hardware?
我忘了哪一个是无线的。哦，不记得了，有……我忘了哪一个是无线的……哦，我想有一个Oculus Quest，对，就是那个，谢谢。所以现在它甚至是无线的，你可以想象你只是戴上这个头显然后去散步，对吧？但是当谈到增强现实（AR）时，你知道，我不认为人们……好吧，首先，我甚至不知道在硬件方面到底有什么，但我不知道人们是否对它看起来的样子有一个很好的心理模型。你能带我们了解一下，现在的增强现实到底是什么吗？我想你提到的那个举起手机的例子，那绝对是每个人都能做到的。但是，你知道，什么是目前最先进的技术，在硬件方面又有什么进展呢？
Absolutely. the state of the art and what's you know coming in terms of hardware absolutely uh so i think the um certainly at zapper our primary mechanism for our primary distribution mechanism i suppose for augmented reality is through your phone so uh experiences where you um you either have an app or a website on your phone that app or website will open up your camera and then from there it will bring your environment to life either your face or your the the table in front of you so for example that app might be a website or a retailer and they're selling vases and you would be able to with this tool picture what the vases would look like by just holding your phone in front of you over your your coffee table and seeing what it would look like in
绝对是。关于最先进的技术以及硬件方面的进展，绝对是……所以我想，嗯，当然在Zappar，我们主要的机制，或者说我认为我们增强现实的主要分发机制是通过你的手机。所以，嗯，那些你……要么在手机上有一个应用程序，要么有一个网站，那个应用程序或网站会打开你的摄像头，然后从那里开始，它会让你的环境变得生动起来，无论是你的脸还是你面前的桌子。例如，那个应用程序可能是一个网站或零售商，他们正在销售花瓶，你就可以通过这个工具，只需把手机举在咖啡桌前，就能看到花瓶放在那里的样子。
place so so that sort of use case for us is where we focus the reason we focus in in mobile handheld distribution mechanisms is because there's a huge market there everybody has a smartphone and and we now have a set of technologies where we can target that device. We have algorithms that run fast enough to facilitate this type of experience on this device. But by no stretch of the imagination is that the only mechanism by which people can have AR experiences. It's just probably the mechanism that those that have will have had it. Yeah, so there are other ways. There are head-mounted pieces of hardware. So Magic Leap, for example, is a company you may have heard of. They make a headset where you put it on your head.
所以，这种用例是我们关注的重点。我们专注于移动手持分发机制的原因是，那里有一个巨大的市场，每个人都有智能手机，而且我们现在有一套技术可以针对该设备。我们拥有的算法运行速度足够快，可以在该设备上促进这种体验。但绝不意味着这是人们获得AR体验的唯一机制。它可能只是那些拥有它的人最常使用的机制。是的，所以还有其他方式。有头戴式硬件。例如，Magic Leap就是你可能听说过的一家公司。他们制造了一种头显，你把它戴在头上。
It has some screens that sit in front of your eyes, but those screens are transparent, but can have content on them. So most of the time when you're wearing this headset, you see the environment around you, but inside that space in front of you, there will be 3D content that appears to you on these screens. As you move your head around, that content will appear rooted into your environment in front of you.
它有一些屏幕放在你的眼睛前面，但这些屏幕是透明的，不过可以显示内容。所以当你戴着这个头显时，大多数时候你看到的是你周围的环境，但在你面前的那个空间里，会有3D内容出现在这些屏幕上。当你移动头部时，这些内容会看起来像是固定在你面前的环境中。
So Microsoft HoloLens, another example of the same type of technology where you have some semi-transparent screen in front of your eyes. We do a similar sort of thing with head-mounted display, but because our focus at Zapper is on things that have mass market distribution, we don't focus so much on expensive headsets or anything like that. We have instead a cardboard-based headset where you use your phone. So much like Google Cardboard did for VR,
所以微软的HoloLens是同类技术的另一个例子，你的眼睛前面有一个半透明的屏幕。我们用头戴式显示器做了类似的事情，但因为我们在Zappar的重点是大众市场分发的产品，所以我们不太关注昂贵的头显之类的东西。相反，我们有一个基于纸板的头显，你可以使用你的手机。就像Google Cardboard为VR所做的那样，
where there's like a cardboard headset, you put your phone in it it's got some lenses in that headset you wear it on your head and you get a VR experience kind of similar to what you would get with Oculus Quest or Oculus Rift or these types of technologies but probably a little bit lower fidelity but still pretty good and given the fact that it costs like a hundredth of the price, you're probably going to be happy. So we've done the same thing for AR with what we call Zapbox. So basically, it's a cardboard headset with lenses. You put your phone in it and you wear that. The phone shows the camera view that it sees in front of it.
有一个纸板头显，你把手机放进去，头显里有一些镜片，你把它戴在头上，就能获得一种类似于Oculus Quest或Oculus Rift或这类技术所能提供的VR体验，虽然保真度可能稍微低一点，但仍然相当不错。考虑到它的价格只有百分之一，你可能会很满意。所以我们用我们称之为Zapbox的产品为AR做了同样的事情。所以基本上，它是一个带有镜片的纸板头显。你把手机放进去，然后戴上它。手机会显示它在前面看到的摄像头画面。
So you see the world around you on the screen of your phone but but close to your head if you like so it looks like you're looking straight through um and then we use our computer vision algorithms rather than any other kind of sensors or camera devices that are attached to the headset we just use the same computer vision algorithms with the sensors that are in your phone to work out where you are in space and to be able to put content into that world in front of you. And then we also have these two cardboard controllers, which they look a bit funny. They've got like black marks all around about them. And we use those marks to work out where those controllers are in space so that as you're holding those controllers and moving them in front of you,
所以你在手机屏幕上看到了你周围的世界，但如果你愿意，它离你的头很近，所以看起来就像你直接看过去一样。然后我们使用我们的计算机视觉算法，而不是连接到头显上的任何其他类型的传感器或摄像头设备，我们只是使用手机中的传感器和相同的计算机视觉算法来计算你在空间中的位置，并能够将内容放入你面前的那个世界中。然后我们还有这两个纸板控制器，它们看起来有点滑稽。它们周围有一些黑色的标记。我们利用这些标记来计算这些控制器在空间中的位置，这样当你拿着这些控制器并在面前移动它们时，
the camera of the phone can see them and recognize where they are. And you use those controllers to interact with the 3D content that's presented in front of you. Wow, that's amazing. So how much does that cost, roughly? So a Snapbox is $30 plus shipping. And so what that gives you is a cardboard headset, the two controllers, and a set of markers that you can put around your environment to help the phone work out what your environment looks like.
手机的摄像头就能看到它们并识别它们的位置。你使用这些控制器与呈现在你面前的3D内容进行交互。哇，那太神奇了。那么这大概要多少钱？Zapbox的价格是30美元加上运费。所以你得到的是一个纸板头显、两个控制器，以及一套你可以放在环境周围的标记，帮助手机计算出你的环境是什么样子的。
We have an interesting constraint with that box, which is because it's on your head, we really do need to be processing frames at 60 FPS. Because if you show the camera to a user on the screen of your phone and it's right up close so that it takes up their whole vision, people are very sensitive to the frame rate and the type of lag you might get from the camera when it's taking up so much of your vision. So we really need to get 60 FPS. And so for that reason, we have a very limited computational budget.
我们在那个盒子上有一个有趣的限制，因为它是戴在头上的，我们确实需要以60 FPS的速度处理帧。因为如果你在手机屏幕上向用户展示摄像头画面，而且它离得很近，占据了他们的整个视野，人们对帧率和当你视野中占据这么多内容时可能产生的延迟非常敏感。所以我们真的需要达到60 FPS。因此，我们有一个非常有限的计算预算。
So every frame of the camera needs to be processed really quickly in order to maintain the 60 FPS we want to maintain. And so we have these markers around which help the algorithms do that. So they're little circles with high contrast elements. And basically what it means is we can find those in the environment much more quickly than it would take to, for example, build a huge environment understanding of an arbitrary space. That makes sense. You have some high pass filter on contrast and then these things come right up. Yeah, exactly.
所以摄像头的每一帧都需要非常快速地处理，以保持我们想要的60 FPS。所以我们周围有这些标记，帮助算法做到这一点。它们是带有高对比度元素的小圆圈。基本上这意味着我们可以在环境中找到它们，比例如构建一个对任意空间的巨大环境理解要快得多。这很有道理。你对对比度有一个高通滤波器，然后这些东西就会立刻显现出来。是的，完全正确。
Exactly. And we are moving to using fewer of those markers and using more of the natural environment around the user just as devices improve and as our algorithms improve. But for the moment, the Zapbox kit includes some of those markers so that you can instrument your environment to help the circumstance. Yeah, a random question here.
完全正确。随着设备和算法的改进，我们正在转向使用更少的标记，并更多地利用用户周围的自然环境。但目前，Zapbox套件包含了一些这样的标记，以便你可以对环境进行配置，从而帮助实现这一情况。是的，这里有一个随机问题。
Why are you showing the camera? So let's assume there's nothing to be shown, nothing to be rendered on the image, right? So like, could you make it so that it's kind of like one of these like mirrors where the camera, you know, if your phone is just a black screen nothing would bounce off this mirror into your eye and you would just look through the mirror to the scene behind you but then if you know the camera if the if the phone was to draw like a white circle on it that would that would show up it's like some way to get the translucent appeal so you because my guess is if you're looking through the camera it's not the same resolution as your eye. No, indeed not. And there is some lag. And it is a bit different to, of course, feels different to actually being in the room and
为什么要显示摄像头画面？假设没有什么东西需要显示，图像上没有什么东西需要渲染，对吧？所以，能不能把它做成那种镜子，如果你的手机只是一个黑屏，没有任何东西会从这个镜子反射到你的眼睛里，你只会透过镜子看到身后的场景，但如果手机在上面画了一个白圈，它就会显示出来，这是一种获得半透明效果的方法。因为我的猜测是，如果你透过摄像头看，它的分辨率和你的眼睛是不一样的。不，确实不是。而且会有一些延迟。当然，这和身处房间里、
seeing the real environment. But there are two elements to that. So one is that if you do have virtual content, you want that virtual content to match up very closely with the real environment. And so if you're instead showing a screen with some virtual content on it, and then the real world behind the user, you have to be able to get those pixels and that 3D content onto that screen so quickly in order for it to match up with the real world environment because normally you have like some latency in the in the ability to render content onto the screen and so if you're not careful you'd have a circumstance where you move your head and of course the light is coming to
看到真实环境的感觉确实不同。但这里有两个要素。一是如果你有虚拟内容，你希望这些虚拟内容与真实环境非常紧密地匹配。所以如果你是在显示一个带有虚拟内容的屏幕，而用户身后是真实世界，你必须能够非常快地将这些像素和3D内容放到屏幕上，以便它与真实世界环境匹配，因为通常你在将内容渲染到屏幕上的能力上会有一些延迟，所以如果你不小心，就会出现当你移动头部时，光线以光速进入人们的眼睛，所以他们瞬间就看到了，但手机可能需要50或100毫秒才能真正把看起来像内容的东西传送到你的眼睛里。在这段时间里，你的头已经移动了一点。所以你会得到这种东西稍微滞后的效果。虚拟内容比真实世界稍微滞后一点。而如果我们做的是在渲染过程中向用户展示摄像头画面，我们可以确保3D内容与当时向用户展示的帧完全匹配。
into people's eyes at the speed of light so they're seeing that instantly but then it's taking the phone maybe like 50 or 100 milliseconds to actually get something into your eye that looks like some content. And during that time, your head will have moved a little bit. So you'd get this kind of effect where things lag a little bit behind. The virtual content lags behind the real world a little bit. Whereas if what we do is we show the camera feed to the user as part of that rendering process, we can make sure that the 3D content is matched up exactly with the frame that is being shown to the user at the time.
所以你不会得到内容和真实世界之间的那种延迟。但代价当然是，用户看到的是这种分辨率较低且稍微滞后的摄像头版本，而不是真实世界环境。我个人认为，如果你专注于虚拟内容，我更喜欢内容能正确地与背景环境对齐。
So you don't get that lag between content and real world. But of course the cost is, the user sees this lower resolution and slightly laggy version of the camera that instead of the real world environment. I personally find that that view is, if you're focusing on the virtual content, I prefer the content to register correctly
我的大脑，我相信其他人的大脑也是，宁愿处理所有东西的延迟，也不愿处理内容和环境之间不同的延迟。话虽如此，肯定有一些解决方案完全符合你所说的，并且在很多情况下工作得非常好。一个例子是头显，你把手机实际上放在你的上方，水平放置……所以手机屏幕指向
with the background environment. My brain, and I'm sure the brain of others, are happy to deal with the lag for everything than have to deal with a disparate lag or difference in lag between the content and the environment. That said, there are definitely solutions which do exactly what you say and work very well in lots of circumstances. So one example is a headset where you place your phone actually above your and and horizontal um so the phone screen is pointing
地面，在手机下方有一个……我想他们称之为半镀银镜，所以它是一个……完全是你描述的那种东西，就像你在警察局审讯室里看到的那种镜子。哦，是的，就像警察看着你被审讯，但你只看到一面镜子。是的，完全正确，或者像电视摄像机前用于提词器的玻璃，演讲者可以阅读提词器屏幕上的文字，但观看电视节目的观众仍然透过这块玻璃观看，但他们自己看不到文字。这是同一种想法，我不明白它是怎么运作的，
down to the ground and below the phone there is uh i think they call it a semi-silvered mirror so it's it's a uh exactly the the thing you describe it's like those mirrors that you get in um the interrogation cells in in police stations oh yeah we're like the police are looking at you being interrogated but you just see a mirror yeah exactly or or the types of glass that sit in front of uh television cameras for the autocues where the where the the um presenter can read what's on the text uh the text on this on this autocue screen but the users who are the users the audience um who are watching the tv show uh are still watching it through this glass but they don't see the the the text themselves it's the same kind of idea and i and i don't understand how it all works
但我认为这与光的偏振有关。哦，有趣。是的。所以你可以有这样一种情况，如果你的内容足够亮，那么你可以在那个屏幕上显示内容，但仍然让身后的环境透过来。所以你得到了虚拟与真实世界环境的结合。在这个例子中，除了环境和内容之间的延迟差异之外，还有一些其他的权衡，那就是很多时候这感觉有点空灵，因为屏幕永远无法使内容完全不透明。所以一切都感觉有点像幽灵。
but i think it's got something to do with the polarization of light. Oh, interesting. Yeah. And so you can have this circumstance where if your content is bright enough, then you can show the content on that screen, but still let the environment behind shine through. So you get the combination of virtual with real world environment. There's a few other kind of trade-offs in that example as well, in addition to the lag difference between the environment and the content, which is that a lot of the time that feels kind of ethereal a little bit because the screen can never make the content completely opaque. So everything feels a little bit ghostly.
哦，那说得通。你可以透过它看到一点环境。是的，这完全说得通。一切看起来都有点像幽灵，或者会看起来像幽灵……但不同的头显使用不同的技术来试图减少这种效果，而且相当多的头显做得相当不错，所以东西看起来确实相当……相当……坚固且不透明。酷，所以有人可以花30美元，基本上用Zapbox把他们的手机变成一种AR头显。我假设网站上列出了手机型号，但它适用于iPhone和Android吗？
Oh, that makes sense. You can see the environment a little bit through it. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Everything kind of looks ghostly or would look ghostly um but the different headsets uh use different technologies to try and reduce that effect and and quite a lot of them do quite a good job so things do appear quite um quite uh solid and opaque cool so someone can go for 30 and30 and basically turn their phone into kind of an AR headset using the Zapbox. I'm assuming on the website it lists phones, but does it work on iPhone and Android?
是的，完全正确。我们有一些，我想说是推荐的设备，因为特别是在Android上，从摄像头获得60 FPS并不总是可能的。所以有一套我们推荐的Android设备，尽管该应用程序可以在大量的Android设备上运行。只是在其中一些设备上你可能会获得更滞后的体验。但大多数从两三代前到现在的iOS设备都运行得非常好。只是可能不包括iPad，因为让iPad放在你的脸前可能行不通。但iPod Touch运行得很好，iPhone也是。
Yeah, exactly. We have a few, I suppose, recommended devices just because particularly on Android, getting 60 FPS from the camera is not always possible. So there are a set of Android devices which we recommend, although the app runs on a ton of Android devices. It's just you might get a kind of more laggy experience on some of them. But most of the iOS devices from two or three generations past till now all work really well. Just maybe not iPads, because getting an iPad to sit in front of your face might not work. But the iPod Touches work well, as do iPhones.
酷。那么让我们进入Zappar。所以Zappar是针对那些想要制作AR内容的人。所以这可能是，比如American Eagle背后的应用程序设计师，他们想要添加一种AR体验。你给出的例子很棒，你穿上他们的一件T恤，他们把这个对齐，对吧？所以他们会使用你们的平台来帮助构建它。是的，完全正确。我们在Zappar的业务有两个方面。一方面是创意内容工作室。所以我们为人们制作内容。但另一方面是我们所说的Zapworks，它是我们的内容开发平台。所以我们有一套工具供任何人使用，去制作这种……
Cool. So let's jump into Zapar. So Zapar is targeted at folks who want to make AR content. So this would be, the app designer behind, let's say, American Eagle, and they want to add an AR experience. The example you gave is great, where you put one of your own t-shirts and they line this one up, right? And so they would use your platform to help build that. Yeah, exactly. We kind of have two sides to our business at Zapper. We have one side, which is a creative content studio. So we make content for people. But the other side is what we call Zapworks, and it's our content development platform. So we have a set of tools for anybody to use to go and make this kind of
内容。它们的复杂程度各不相同，有些真的很容易使用。假设你想让你的名片变得生动起来，带上一些按钮，比如浏览你的网站，或者给你发电子邮件，或者链接到你的社交网站，或者也许你想在上面放一个你录制的视频，它可能会像在名片表面上一样播放。所以我们有一些更简单的工具，可以帮助你非常容易地制作那种东西。然后我们有一些IDE，如果你愿意的话，也就是一些功能齐全的3D开发环境，用于构建内容，感觉有点像游戏引擎。所以如果你曾经用Unity或那种工具构建过东西，那么这就是这个工具的感觉。它为你提供了一个3D环境。
content. And they range in complexity from some that are really easy to use. Let's say you want to bring your business card to life with some buttons for like going through your or sending you an email or perhaps linking to your social sites, or perhaps you want to have a video on there that you've recorded that might play as if it's on the surface of the business card. So we've got some simpler tools that help you make that sort of thing really easily. Then we have some IDEs, if you like, so some fully fledged 3D development environments for building content, which feel a bit like a game engine. So if you've ever built something with Unity or that type of tool, then that's what this tool feels like. It gives you a 3D environment.
你可以导入3D模型，你可以编写体验脚本，然后它理解所有这些不同的跟踪类型。所以你可以说，我想让我的角色，3D模型角色在我的桌子上走动。所以你会有世界跟踪器，你把你的3D模型角色拖进去，让它在我的桌子上走动。或者也许你设计了一顶帽子，一顶3D模型帽子。
You can import 3D models, you can script the experience, and then it understands all of these different tracking types. So you could say, I'd like my character, 3D model character to walk around on my table. And so you would have a world tracker and you drag your 3D model character to walk around on my table. And so you would have a world tracker and you'd drag your 3D model into that. Or perhaps you have designed a hat, a 3D model hat.
你可以说，我想创建一个面部跟踪体验，你可以把你的帽子拖进去，并定位它，这样它就会出现在人的头上。而且这一切都与发布平台集成在一起，所以你可以立即发布该内容，用户可以通过我们的应用程序、网络或集成到其他应用程序中的我们的技术来访问它。然后还有最后一个要素，
You could say, I want to create a face-tracked experience and you could drag your hat in and position it so that it would appear on the person's head. And that's all integrated with a publishing platform so you can publish that content straight away, and users can access it either through our app or through the web or through our technology integrated into other apps. Then there's one final element,
那就是所有这些计算机视觉算法，我们也将其作为一套SDK公开，这样人们就可以在他们自己的应用程序、程序或其他创意工具中使用它们。例如，我们有一个Unity的SDK。所以你可以用Unity构建一种游戏体验，使用我们的面部跟踪、世界跟踪或图像跟踪等。那么这是如何工作的呢？其实，有一件事很快问一下。网页版是如何工作的？
which is all of these computer vision algorithms, we also expose as a set of SDKs, so people can use them in their own applications or programs or other creative tools. So we have an SDK for Unity, for example. So you could build with Unity a gameplay type experience using our face tracking or our world tracking or image tracking, etc. So how does this work? Actually, one thing real quick. How does the web version work?
所以有人会用手机访问一个网站，它会以某种方式启动这种体验，我想是使用HTML5和WebGL以及所有这些技术。是的，完全正确。对于我们来说，网络是一个超级有趣的领域。在很多方面，它比应用商店对用户来说方便得多。所以，你知道，用户可以非常快地访问网站。网络现在拥有大量的技术来帮助我们做这种事情。
So someone would go to a website on their phone, and it would somehow start this experience, I guess, using HTML5 and WebGL and all of that. Yeah, exactly. And the web for us is a super interesting space. It's very much more convenient for users in a lot of ways than app stores. So, you know, users can get to websites really quickly. The web now has a ton of technologies that help us do this sort of thing.
对于我们Zappar来说，这尤其有趣，因为我们有一个竞争优势，有点自私地说，我们的算法，我们在Zappar已经在这个领域待了很长时间了。所以我们的算法经过了相当程度的优化。而且其中很多是为那些计算资源比我们现在的大型智能手机少的设备而构思的。
It's particularly interesting for us at Zapier also because we have, it's a competitive advantage for us, a little bit selfishly, in that our algorithms, we've been kind of on the block for quite a long time at Zapper. So our algorithms are quite heavily optimized. And also lots of them conceived for devices which have less computational resources than our big smartphones do now.
这意味着这些算法已经很好地转化为让我们在网络浏览器中运行它们。哇，真的很酷。是的，所以你会做的是，是的，你会用手机打开一个网站，你可能先扫描了一个二维码，或者也许有人只是给了你一个URL或社交媒体上的链接，它会像任何其他网页一样带你进入一个网页。然后应用程序或网站会提示打开你的摄像头，就像你在手机上使用Zoom或Google Meet一样。在某些情况下，我们也会在iOS上请求传感器数据，例如加速度计和陀螺仪数据。是的，这说得通。
And that means that those algorithms have translated well for us to run them in web browsers. Wow, really cool yeah so what you would do is yeah you'd open your your phone to a website you might have done that by scanning a qr code first or maybe someone's just giving you a url or a link on social and it takes you to a web page like any other uh the app or the website will then prompt to open your camera like as as if you were using Zoom or Google Meet or something on your phone. In some cases, we'll also, on iOS, for example, request sensor data, so accelerometer and gyro data. Yeah, it makes sense.
iOS上的运动数据。网站需要权限才能获取这些数据，所以我们也要求获取这些权限。但随后在那个网页中，你会看到摄像头，无论是自拍镜头还是后置镜头。然后就像在应用程序中一样，当你环顾你的环境时，我们可以为它带来内容。
Motion data on iOS. And websites require permission for that, so we ask for that as well. But then in that web page, you'll see the camera, either the selfie camera or the rear facing camera. And then much like it would in the app, as you look around your environment, we can bring content to that.
是的，我们使用了大量的有趣的网络技术。你提到了WebGL，我们用它来进行3D渲染。我们使用Get User Media，这是用于在网络浏览器中访问摄像头的API。我们使用一种叫做WebAssembly的技术，它让我们能够使用不是用JavaScript编写的代码。所以我想网络的语言是JavaScript，那是你用来编写网络内容的自然编程语言。但WebAssembly让你能够使用用其他编程语言编写的代码，并将它们用于网络。我们的许多算法都是用C和C++编写的，
Yeah, and there's a ton of interesting constituent web technologies we use there. So you mentioned WebGL, which we use in order to do the 3D rendering. We use Get User Media, which is the API for accessing the camera in the web browser. We use a technology called WebAssembly, which lets us take code that's not written in JavaScript. So I suppose the language of the web is JavaScript, and that's the kind of natural programming language you would use to write content for the web. But WebAssembly lets you take code that's written in other programming languages and use them for the web. And lots of our algorithms are written in C and C++,
而WebAssembly允许我们在网络浏览器中非常快速地运行它们。这说得通。过去有一种东西叫Emscripten。WebAssembly是它的进化版吗？是的。所以我想它实际上是一个进化版，但实际上Emscripten现在的作用是为WebAssembly提供一个环境。WebAssembly实际上是网络浏览器中一种核心的原始技术，让你能够运行这种类型的代码。但当你使用像C和C++这样的语言编码时，
and WebAssembly allows us to run those in the web browser very quickly. That makes sense. There used to be something called an Emscripten. Is WebAssembly like an evolution of that? Yeah. So I suppose effectively it is an evolution, but actually what Emscripten serves to do now is provide an environment for WebAssembly. WebAssembly is quite actually a core kind of raw technology in a web browser that lets you run this type of code. But when you're coding in a language like C and C++,
除了编译器生成的机器代码之外，还有很多元素可以让事情运作。所以你有所谓的标准库。这是一组与你的程序一起运行的程序，你编写的程序，让你能够访问文件，例如，或者网络或摄像头。所以标准库是一组伴随你程序的工具。而WebAssembly技术不提供任何标准库，但Emscripten现在起到了这个作用。
there are lots more elements than just the machine code that the compiler produces that makes things work. So you have what's called a standard library. And that's a set of programs that run along with your program, the program you've written, that let you access files, for example, or the network or the camera. And so the standard library is a set of tools that accompany your program. And the WebAssembly technology doesn't provide any standard library, but Emscripten now serves that purpose.
所以如果你正在构建并采用一个你之前用C++编写的程序，你用Emscripten编译它，Emscripten会把它编译成WebAssembly，但也会提供这些你需要的额外库的实现，以便让你的程序运行。哦，我明白了。是的。所以Emscripten，我想，最初是针对一种叫做Asim.js的技术，
So if you're building and you're taking a program that you'd previously written in C++, you compile it with Emscripten, Emscripten will compile it into WebAssembly, but will also provide implementations of these extra libraries that you need in order to make your program run. Oh, I see. Yeah. And so Emscripten, I suppose, originally started targeting a technology called Asim.js,
它是WebAssembly的前身。所以Asim.js之于WebAssembly，我想。这些是等效的技术。然后Emscripten在这些技术之上充当了一层。明白了，我想。所以基本上，就像，你编写一个C++程序。在那个程序中，你调用Quicksort。所以底层发生的事情是它转到STL
which is the kind of precursor to WebAssembly. So Asim.js is to WebAssembly, I suppose. Those are the equivalent technologies. And then Emscripten serves as a layer on top of those. Got it, I guess. So basically, like, you write a C++ program. In that program, you call Quicksort. And so what happens under the hood is it goes to the STL
或这些标准库之一并获取Quicksort。浏览器上的问题是，你知道，你没有Quicksort。所以Emscripten提供了一种WebAssembly版本的这一切。是的，完全正确。另一种方式是，假设你已经使用OpenGL用C++构建了一个3D程序。所以OpenGL是一个用于原生程序的API，允许你使用计算机上的显卡将3D元素绘制到屏幕上。所以，例如，你可能，像电脑游戏，
or one of these standard libraries and fetches Quicksort. The issues on the browser, you know, you don't have Quicksort. And so Emscripten kind of provides like WebAssembly versions of all of that. Yeah, exactly. And another way is, let's say you've built a 3D program in C++ using OpenGL. So OpenGL is an API for native programs that allow you to use the graphics card on your computer to draw 3D elements to your screen. So, for example, you might, like computer games,
会使用OpenGL将内容渲染到你的屏幕上。如果你已经使用OpenGL编写了C和C++应用程序，然后你想使用Emscripten将它们移植到网络浏览器中运行。网络浏览器并没有完全相同的API集。它们有一套稍微不同但相似的API，叫做WebGL，它有一套不同的限制和稍微不同的API。
will use OpenGL to render content onto your screen. And if you've written applications in C and C++ using OpenGL, and then you want to use, to port those using Emscripten to run in the web browser. The web browser doesn't have exactly the same set of APIs. They have a slightly different but similar set called WebGL, which has a different set of constraints and slightly different API.
Emscripten所做的是，它为你的代码提供了一套类似于你编写程序时使用的原始OpenGL的API，但随后会代表你实际上在后台运行等效的WebGL，这样你就不必修改你的程序来理解WebGL。Emscripten会将你的OpenGL转换为WebGL。酷。是的，这真的很迷人。是的，所以，是的，这真的很棒。所以如果有人想要，假设外面有人想要学习这项技术，对吧？所以他们会得到Zapworks SDK。
What Emscripten does is it provides to your code a set of APIs that are like the original OpenGL you brought your program for, but then takes those and actually runs the equivalent WebGL behind the scenes on your behalf so that you don't have to modify your program to understand WebGL. Emscripten will translate your OpenGL into WebGL. Cool. Yeah, that's really fascinating. Yeah, and so, yeah, this is really awesome. So if somebody wants to, let's say there's somebody out there who wants to learn this technology, right? So they would get the Zapworks SDK.
假设他们想要，只是用一个简单的例子，让当你触摸表面时，一个球弹出来之类的。所以他们会采用这个SDK，他们会围绕它制作一个应用程序，一个应用程序的外壳。会有某种方式来触发它，比如当一个人点击表面时，会有某种逻辑来
Let's say they wanted to, just to use a simple example, make it so when you touched on a surface, a ball popped out of it or something. So they would take this SDK, they would make an app, a shell of an app around that. There would be some way to sort of trigger it, say when a person taps on the surface, there's some sort of logic to
处理它……然后……他们会说我想让这个球飞出来，你知道……平行于这个表面的法线，在底层Zappar正在做我们刚才谈到的所有繁重工作，甚至更多。是的，完全正确，而且不同……我们工具的不同特定部分，这在语法上不太正确。我们不同的工具以稍微不同的机制暴露这种使用。称之为……但它是一种用于制作内容的3D开发环境，你只需要担心的是，比如我想跟踪环境，我有一个球的3D模型，然后你可能有一点脚本，你把它附加到像指针事件上，也就是那个表面上的手指点击事件，然后你会说，好的，当用户点击那个表面时，我想显示球，然后给它一些速度，或者让它进行动画，如果你愿意的话，向上移动。然后你可以发布它，用户就可以在浏览器或应用程序中或任何地方立即访问它。
handle that um and then and then um they would say i want this ball to fly out you know uh parallel to the normal on this surface and and under the hood zapar is doing all of that that heavy lifting that we just talked about and more yeah exactly and different different. And different particular ones of our tools, that's not very grammatically correct. Our different tools expose that type of use in a slightly different mechanism. call it but it's a kind of 3d development environment for making content all you need to worry about there is is be like i want to track the environment i've got the 3d model of a ball and then you might have a little bit of script which you attach to like a pointer event so a finger tapping event on that surface and then you'll say okay when the user taps on that surface i want to show the ball and then give it some velocity or take it along an animation, if you like, going upwards. And then you can publish that and then users can access that straight away in the browser or through the app or wherever.
或者，如果你正在使用我们的低级SDK之一，我们的低级SDK所做的是告诉你的代码，表面在这里，表面在这里，表面在这里，表面在这里，每一帧，然后你可以以任何你希望的方式将其合并到你的程序中。所以假设你在Unity中这样做，那么Unity将有一些机制来计算当用户点击屏幕时，然后由你来决定如何在Unity中在正确的位置创建网格并赋予它速度。我们还有其他针对3JS的SDK，例如。所以3JS是一个用于JavaScript的库，使得制作3D内容变得容易。
Alternatively, if you're using one of our lower level SDKs, what our lower level SDK will do is tell your code, the surface is here, the surface is here, the surface is here, the surface is here, every frame, and then you can incorporate that into your program however you wish. So let's say you're doing that in Unity, then Unity will have some mechanism for working out how when the user taps on the screen, then it's up to you to work out how to create the mesh in the right place in Unity and give it the velocity. We also have other SDKs that target 3JS, for example. So 3JS is a library for JavaScript that makes it easy to make 3D content.
它是一个编程库。所以用JavaScript，你会用它来构建3D体验。然后我们针对3JS的SDK只会给你一个3JS中的组，这是一个，我想，一个3JS概念。然后由你来决定当用户点击那里时，并，你知道，把球放在那里，并使用3JS API让球在正确的地方渲染出来。酷，这说得通。所以然后，在另一个方向上，在最高级别，你有这个……你有一个真正的设计工作室，或者如果有人想要……你知道，也许为了他们的工作场所，他们想要一些非常专业的内容，那么你能够提供更多的实践经验。是的，完全正确，而且在……这是我们开始的业务部分。所以回到过去，我的商业伙伴和我，我们正在把这个作为一个研究项目，
It's a programming library. So in JavaScript, you would use it to build a 3D experience. And then our SDK for 3GS will just give you a group in 3GS, which is, I suppose, a 3GS concept. And then it would be up to you to work out when the user's tapped there and to, you know, put the ball there and using the 3GS api make the ball render up in the right place cool that makes sense and so then working uh in the other direction at the highest level you have this um you have like a real design studio or if someone wanted um you know maybe for their for their place of employment they wanted some really professional content then you're able to sort of provide more hands-on experience yeah exactly and in, that's the bit of our business that we started with. So back in the day, my business partner and I, we were working on this as a research project,
它是一个编程库。在JavaScript中，你可以用它来构建3D体验。我们的3GS SDK会为你提供一个3GS中的组，这应该是一个3GS的概念。然后由你来决定用户何时点击那里，并在那里放置球，并使用3GS API让球在正确的位置渲染出来。酷，这很有道理。那么在另一个方向上，在最高层级，你拥有一个真正的设计工作室，或者如果有人想为他们的工作场所制作一些非常专业的内容，那么你能够提供更多的实践经验。是的，完全正确。这正是我们业务起步的部分。所以回到过去，我和我的商业伙伴当时正在把这个作为一个研究项目来做。
this type of technology at university. And we had some commercial interest in these algorithms, and so we set up Zapper along with two others. And originally, the purpose of the company was to provide this type of content for businesses and brands who wanted to have these interesting, rich content experiences with their users. But in order to fulfill that work, in order to do that for our clients and
这类技术在大学里。我们对这些算法有一些商业兴趣，所以我们和其他两个人一起成立了 Zapper。最初，公司的目的是为那些希望与用户进行有趣、丰富的内容体验的企业和品牌提供这类内容。但为了完成这项工作，为了给我们的客户做到这一点，
customers, we had to build these tools to make it easy for us to do. And then for the last three or four years or so, those tools have been a mature enough product that we then sell those tools as a product for anyone to use. So it's a true case of dog feeding, like we're eating our own dog food, we made the tools so that we could use them. But it turns out they're actually very useful tools for anybody that wants to make this type of content. Very, very cool. So what's the, so focusing on the tools, what's the sort of pricing, like what's the business model there? And as part of that question, you know, if someone is a student, can they get their hands on a free version and how does all of that work?
我们必须构建这些工具，以便我们能轻松地完成工作。在过去的三四年里，这些工具已经足够成熟，我们便将它们作为产品出售给任何人使用。这确实是一个“吃自己狗粮”的案例，我们制作这些工具是为了自己使用。但事实证明，对于任何想要制作这类内容的人来说，它们确实是非常有用的工具。非常非常酷。那么，专注于这些工具，定价模式是怎样的？商业模式是什么？作为这个问题的一部分，如果有人是学生，他们能获得免费版本吗？这一切是如何运作的？
Yeah, absolutely. So for personal use, it's free to use. So you can just head to zap.works and get a personal account and you can use pretty much all of our tools with the free account. There are a few things like the kind of analytics and stuff that only really commercial users would be interested in, which are not available for personal, but otherwise a personal account
是的，当然。个人使用是免费的。你可以直接前往 zap.works 注册一个个人账户，几乎可以使用我们所有的工具。有一些功能，比如分析等，只有商业用户才会感兴趣，这些功能不向个人用户开放，但除此之外，个人账户
has access to all of the tools. And so if you're a student that's using it for your studies or something like that, then you can totally use the personal account for that purpose. We have an education tier as well. That's primarily for if an institution is buying our tools
可以使用所有工具。所以，如果你是一名学生，为了学习或其他目的使用它，你完全可以使用个人账户。我们也有教育层级。这主要是为了机构购买我们的工具
to use as part of a teaching or for promotional purposes. And it's just a significant significant discount uh on our otherwise uh plans and it's the the product is structured a little bit so you can have teachers and students and and you know permissions are all set up so that teachers can see what the students have made but the students can't delete each other's content and that sort of thing yeah that makes sense yeah but then if you're using it for a business, we have a few different tiers. They start from about $100 a month. And you basically pay on a per user basis for access to the tools, much like you would with something like Creative Cloud from Adobe.
作为教学或宣传用途。它在我们其他计划的基础上提供了相当大的折扣，产品结构也经过了一些调整，你可以设置教师和学生，权限也都设置好了，这样教师可以看到学生制作的内容，但学生不能删除彼此的内容，诸如此类。是的，这很有道理。但如果你是用于商业用途，我们有几种不同的层级。起价大约是每月 100 美元。你基本上是按用户付费来获取工具的使用权，就像使用 Adobe 的 Creative Cloud 那样。
Yes, that makes sense. And as part of this tool, we provide a lot of hosting. So if you want to host your content so that people can access it either through the web or through the apps, we can host that all through our district content distribution network. So it's a really easy process to publish and get your content out there. And so we have like a kind of overage on each of the plans so that if you get all of a sudden millions of people scanning your content, then there's like a pair scan fee just so that basically we don't end up with this huge hosting bill. Yeah, I've definitely, definitely been there. I mean, we at one point we tried moving the podcast to from one provider to another. And that second provider wasn't the economy of scale was a little bit different.
是的，这很有道理。作为该工具的一部分，我们提供了大量的托管服务。所以，如果你想托管你的内容，以便人们可以通过网络或应用程序访问它，我们可以通过我们的内容分发网络来托管所有这些内容。所以发布和分发你的内容是一个非常简单的过程。我们在每个计划中都有一定的超额限制，所以如果突然有数百万人扫描你的内容，就会有一个按扫描次数收费的费用，这样我们基本上就不会面临巨额的托管账单。是的，我绝对经历过这种情况。我的意思是，我们曾经尝试将播客从一个提供商迁移到另一个提供商。而第二个提供商的规模经济有点不同。
And, yeah, you'd easily rack up a very hefty bill if you're not careful. And so, yeah, you definitely need those guardrails in place yeah it's funny it's one of these things that if you think like we don't seem to kind of understand as human beings an exponential increase so if you go from like 10,000 to 100,000 it doesn't really seem to us that much of a difference somehow like but but it is 10 times more or if you go from 100,000 to a million maybe a million is a little bit different because it's so kind of ingrained in our psyche as a number. But, you know, if you have a million people accessing your content, you've had 10 amounts of 100,000 people accessing your content, which doesn't seem like, I mean, it seems like I'm stating the obvious, but 10 times however much you paid for 100,000 is going to, you're going to notice that in your wallet rather than yeah there's this i've been reading um
而且，是的，如果你不小心，很容易就会产生巨额账单。所以，是的，你绝对需要那些护栏。是的，这很有趣，这是我们人类似乎不太理解指数级增长的事情之一。所以如果你从 1 万增加到 10 万，我们似乎觉得差别并不大，但实际上是 10 倍。或者如果你从 10 万增加到 100 万，也许 100 万有点不同，因为它作为一个数字已经深深植根于我们的心理中。但是，你知道，如果你有 100 万人访问你的内容，你就有了 10 个 10 万人的访问量，这似乎……我的意思是，这听起来像是在说废话，但 10 倍于你为 10 万人支付的费用，你会注意到你的钱包缩水了，而不是……是的，我一直在读……
um there's this uh book i've been reading philosophy for kids i've been i've been reading it with my kids and um there's this one philosopher and i'm not gonna remember the name he's actually an indian philosopher that much i remember but but his thing was basically the king kind of wanted to exile this person. And they said, you know, you can just make a request for me. I'll give you this request and then just leave the kingdom. And the request he made was, he said, take this chessboard and go from left to right, put one grain of rice on one square and then two on the next and four on the next, and then just keep doing that pattern. And then I'll take the whole row and then I'll go. And, or maybe, I don't know if it was a chess board because yeah, two to the eighth is only
嗯，我一直在读一本给孩子看的哲学书，我和我的孩子们一起读，嗯，里面有一个哲学家，我不记得名字了，他实际上是一位印度哲学家，我只记得这么多，但他的观点基本上是国王想流放这个人。他们说，你知道，你可以向我提一个要求。我会满足你的要求，然后离开王国。他提出的要求是，他说，拿这个棋盘，从左到右，在一个格子里放一粒米，然后在下一个格子里放两粒，再下一个放四粒，就这样一直重复这个模式。然后我会拿走整行，然后我就走。或者也许，我不知道那是不是棋盘，因为 2 的 8 次方只有
200. Maybe it was, it was, it was another game or something, but, but yeah, basically you just, the exponential, you know, the King said, sure. And then you quickly realize that it's more than there are grains of rice in the universe or something right so it's just it's just yeah people have a really hard time grasping grasping that and um what i what i tell i recently did an interview where we talked about um podcasting and i answered a lot of questions about this particular show and that was one of the things i touched on was you know if you, let's say 300 listeners and two of them, you know, have a feature request, if you go to 300,000 listeners, you're going to get 2000 of those, of those requests. And if you're getting two of those a week, now you're getting 2000 emails a week just for feature requests. And yeah, it's a hard
200。也许是另一个游戏什么的，但基本上你只是……指数级增长，你知道，国王说，没问题。然后你很快就会意识到，这比宇宙中的米粒还要多，或者类似的东西，所以人们真的很难理解这一点。我最近做了一个采访，我们谈到了播客，我回答了很多关于这个特定节目的问题，这是我提到的事情之一，你知道，如果你有 300 个听众，其中两个有功能请求，如果你增加到 30 万听众，你就会得到 2000 个这样的请求。如果你每周收到两个这样的请求，现在你每周就会收到 2000 封关于功能请求的电子邮件。是的，这真的很难
thing to really grasp. I wonder why that is. I wonder what part of our psyche makes it difficult to grasp, you know, exponential or multiplicative things. Yeah, it's super fascinating. And I think we're kind of lucky as programmers that in a lot of ways we are taught to not trust our intuition when it comes to scale and complexity. A lot of the time, you know, lots of these, you know, if you're studying computer science and you're learning about algorithms and all of these things and big O notation,
真正理解。我想知道为什么会这样。我想知道我们心理的哪一部分使得理解指数级或乘法级的事物变得困难。是的，这非常迷人。我认为作为程序员，我们很幸运，在很多方面我们被教导不要在规模和复杂性方面相信我们的直觉。很多时候，你知道，如果你在学习计算机科学，学习算法和所有这些东西以及大 O 表示法，
you know, very quickly in that process, realize that trying to intuitively work out how a particular sort mechanism is going to scale is something that's quite difficult to do. You kind of need to start modeling it or doing the proofs to try and work out how something scales. So I think as a community, we do better than maybe other communities do in terms of understanding that or at least it's just learning not to trust our intuition on it yeah that's right yeah yeah and
你知道，在这个过程中很快就会意识到，试图凭直觉算出某种排序机制将如何扩展是相当困难的。你需要开始建模或进行证明来尝试算出某事如何扩展。所以我认为作为一个社区，我们在理解这一点方面比其他社区做得更好，或者至少是学会了不要相信我们的直觉。是的，没错。
it comes down to the or we see the same thing as you say with with trying to understand non-computational concepts as well and how you scale something like support or feedback and these sorts of things is super interesting. And, you know, as a developer of a product, it's also a fascinating process where you see lots of feedback that you get in for a particular product, and you have to discern which elements of those are those that you should prioritize,
归根结底，或者正如你所说，我们在试图理解非计算概念时也看到了同样的情况，以及你如何扩展支持或反馈等这类事情是非常有趣的。而且，作为产品的开发者，这也是一个迷人的过程，你会看到针对特定产品获得的大量反馈，你必须辨别哪些元素是你应该优先考虑的，
that make sense for large numbers of your users and that are feasible. And I find that process fascinating as well. Because inevitably, you're going to get a ton of users that said, but I gave you this amazing idea and you never implemented it. And I think it would be the best idea for your product ever. And what they don't see is that you've also had, you know, 1,999 other similar amazing ideas. And you've had to go with the one that, you know, you thought would push the needle a bit more or would help more users.
这些元素对大量用户有意义且可行。我也觉得这个过程很迷人。因为不可避免地，你会得到一大堆用户说，但我给了你这个绝妙的主意，你却从来没有实现它。我认为这将是你产品有史以来最好的主意。而他们没有看到的是，你也收到了 1999 个其他类似的绝妙主意。你必须选择那个你认为能推动更多进展或能帮助更多用户的方案。
Yeah, totally. Yeah, so the product sounds awesome. I think everyone should check this out. Totally free to try this out. And if you do end up making the ball coming out of the surface, send that. I mean, that would be awesome. If there's a website where we could just go and try that out, we'll post it in the show notes if anyone builds that or anything, really. I think it'd be really fascinating to try it out. What's it like to kind of work at Zapper and, you know, what sort of a day in the life of an engineer there? And especially if there's anything kind of that really stands out that people kind of wouldn't expect that's kind of unique, right? And, you know, are there sort of positions available what kind of folks are you looking for
是的，完全正确。是的，所以这个产品听起来很棒。我认为每个人都应该看看。完全免费试用。如果你最终做出了那个从表面出来的球，发给我。我的意思是，那会很棒。如果有一个网站我们可以去试用一下，如果有人构建了那个或任何东西，我们会在节目说明中发布它。我认为试用一下会非常迷人。在 Zapper 工作是什么感觉，工程师的一天是怎样的？特别是如果有什么真正突出的、人们意想不到的独特之处吗？而且，是否有职位空缺，你们在寻找什么样的人？
uh yeah i think one of the most uh interesting things for me at zapper is we have a hugely diverse range of skills at zapper and job roles so our uh business because we have this side of business that's a creative uh development studio as well as having our platform side of our business, so the side that makes these tools, we end up with designers, we have 3D artists, we have content developers who are using JavaScript and TypeScript day-to-day to build AR experiences. And then, and I suppose the team that I look after, we have web developers who are working on web-based AR creative tools. We have people looking after our content management system. So Zapworks allows you, as we mentioned, to host content and publish it for users. And so we have a management system for that. So there are people developing and working on that. We have our support team as well who help our users and users of our tools get the most out of those tools and answer any questions that they might have. We have a QA team and sales and business development. So there's a huge different number of roles.
嗯，是的，我认为对我来说在 Zapper 最有趣的事情之一是我们在 Zapper 拥有极其多样化的技能和工作角色。我们的业务因为既有创意开发工作室的一面，也有我们业务的平台端，也就是制作这些工具的一面，所以我们最终有设计师、3D 艺术家、每天使用 JavaScript 和 TypeScript 构建 AR 体验的内容开发者。然后，我想我负责的团队，我们有从事基于网络的 AR 创意工具的 Web 开发人员。我们有人负责我们的内容管理系统。所以 Zapworks 允许你，正如我们提到的，托管内容并为用户发布它。所以我们有一个管理系统。所以有人在开发和维护它。我们还有支持团队，他们帮助我们的用户和工具的使用者充分利用这些工具，并回答他们可能有的任何问题。我们有 QA 团队、销售和业务开发。所以有大量不同的角色。
And that's what makes Zapper really interesting. The people that we get to work with are all an incredibly talented bunch and are all really fun to work with. And it means also, maybe this is the unique element, but it's maybe interesting for us, but not necessarily an interesting insight, which is that it changes a lot. We work on lots of different content all the time, and we have lots of interesting new technology that we're working on and new tools that we're building all the time. So it never really stands still very much. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, you're right at the forefront of something. So, you know, I feel that's one of the challenges with the smartphone is, you know, if know, even, you know, I mean, the plan is just to give it away for free, but it's hard to even do that because, you know, it's like what
这就是让 Zapper 非常有趣的原因。我们一起工作的人都是一群非常有才华的人，和他们一起工作真的很有趣。这也意味着，也许这是独特的元素，但对我们来说可能很有趣，但不一定是一个有趣的见解，那就是它变化很大。我们一直在处理许多不同的内容，我们一直在研究许多有趣的新技术，并一直在构建新工具。所以它从来不会停滞不前。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，你正处于某些事物的前沿。所以，我觉得这是智能手机面临的挑战之一，你知道，即使计划只是免费赠送，但即使这样做也很难，因为，你知道，就像什么
keyword hasn't really been taken or how will people be able to find this when there's just so much content out there? And the platform that you're working on is really a green field, you know, and who knows when that device will come out, or even when the environment changes as it has with the COVID-19, that causes that huge explosion of growth, right? So it's like a great time to be in this area. Absolutely.
关键词还没有被真正占用，或者当有这么多内容时，人们将如何找到它？你正在工作的平台确实是一片蓝海，谁知道那个设备什么时候会出来，或者当环境像 COVID-19 那样发生变化时，这会导致巨大的增长爆发，对吧？所以这是一个进入这个领域的绝佳时机。绝对是。
And I think to your point about apps and trying to kind of outshine other apps and what have you, I think what we'll see is a continuation that the web is the ultimate app delivery platform, if you like. And in the same way, you know, if we're making a website, we will do perhaps SEO optimization to try and, you know, make it so that users find our site. Or we look to social media or, you know, lots of other forms of getting our websites out there for people who are interested to find them. We never kind of think, you know, how am I going to make my website appear near the top of the big list of websites that there is? There's no big list of websites. Yeah, that's a really good point. Yeah. And so I suspect that we will continue to see the web just blossom and more and more the types of
关于应用程序和试图超越其他应用程序等等，我认为我们将看到的是网络是终极应用程序交付平台的延续。同样，如果我们正在制作一个网站，我们可能会进行 SEO 优化，试图让用户找到我们的网站。或者我们寻求社交媒体，或者其他许多让我们的网站被感兴趣的人找到的方式。我们从来不会想，我要怎么让我的网站出现在那个巨大的网站列表的顶部？根本没有巨大的网站列表。是的，这是一个很好的观点。所以，我怀疑我们将继续看到网络蓬勃发展，越来越多的
applications that we would be used to having as apps on our phones will actually access through really nice and tightly implemented web applications. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, also you have a truly neutral platform, right? I mean, I think the app store, you know, I know where I work at now, there's tons of challenges with getting apps approved. It takes forever, even when there aren't issues, right? And you just have kind of like this constant gatekeeper, at least on iOS. On Android, I don't know too much about the Android App Store experience.
我们习惯于在手机上作为应用程序使用的应用程序，实际上将通过非常漂亮且实现紧密的 Web 应用程序来访问。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，你也有一个真正中立的平台，对吧？我的意思是，我认为应用商店，我知道我现在工作的地方，在获得应用程序批准方面有很多挑战。即使没有问题，也需要很长时间，对吧？你基本上有一个持续的守门人，至少在 iOS 上是这样。在 Android 上，我对 Android 应用商店的体验了解不多。
My guess is it's similar. Maybe the turnaround time is faster. Oh, no, actually, you can publish without any review, right, on Android? It certainly used to be the case, no, actually, you can publish without any review, right, on Android? It certainly used to be the case, yes, although different apps on Google do get reviewed now, but I think they're kind of triaged and apps which are considered by Google to be more worthy of close inspection will take longer. So I think, for example, if you're part of the Design the designed for families program they will have a closer look at your app or if you request certain sets of permissions and what have you yeah yeah but the web is uh you know it's you don't have to install anything like the the app installs when you go to the website and uninstalls when you leave every
我猜是类似的。也许周转时间更快。哦，不，实际上，在 Android 上你可以不经过任何审查就发布，对吧？确实曾经是这样，是的，尽管谷歌上的不同应用程序现在确实会受到审查，但我认为它们被分类了，谷歌认为更值得仔细检查的应用程序需要更长的时间。所以，例如，如果你是“为家庭设计”计划的一部分，他们会更仔细地查看你的应用程序，或者如果你请求某些权限等等。是的，但网络是……你知道，你不需要安装任何东西，就像当你去网站时应用程序会安装，当你离开时会卸载，每次
time you know yeah yeah exactly and i think you, there are lots of reasons why I think that having the web is a healthy thing for society in terms of it being, you know, it doesn't have gatekeepers necessarily. Of course, you know, websites are still bound by the laws that exist in our various different countries. countries that doesn't stop some websites yeah right yeah but at the end of the day uh the only thing that stops you publishing a website is your you know creative the point where you decide i'm willing to get this out there and make it and see what happens um yeah and i think that's good that's good for a society um and it's a reason i think why you know as these web browsers get better they're able to expose more of the devices technology-wise like we were speaking about WebAssembly and and get user media the camera API for example I think we'll get to a place where where the web is just the ultimate application platform and it will be the exception rather than rule when you have to be running
都是这样。是的，完全正确。我认为有很多原因让我认为拥有网络对社会来说是一件健康的事情，因为它没有守门人。当然，网站仍然受到我们各个国家现行法律的约束。这并不能阻止某些网站。是的，但归根结底，唯一阻止你发布网站的是你的创造力，当你决定我愿意把它发布出去并看看会发生什么的时候。我认为这对社会有好处。这也是为什么随着网络浏览器变得越来越好，它们能够暴露更多设备的技术功能，就像我们谈到的 WebAssembly 和获取用户媒体，例如相机 API，我认为我们将达到一个网络就是终极应用程序平台的阶段，当你必须在设备上运行
native code on on a device as part of a big proper installation. Yeah, totally makes sense. So are you folks hiring? Are there internships? Are there full-time positions? What does that look like right now? Yeah, well, we do have a set of roles up at zapper.com, our careers page there. So definitely worth looking at. Throughout the kind of latter half of this year, we are beginning to think more about not necessarily having to have everybody in London, which is interesting just because we are, you know, thanks to the big COVID word, we are embracing working from wherever you like, working from where you
原生代码作为大型安装的一部分时，那将是例外而不是规则。是的，完全有道理。那么你们在招聘吗？有实习吗？有全职职位吗？现在情况如何？是的，我们在 zapper.com 的职业页面上有一系列职位。所以绝对值得一看。在今年下半年，我们开始更多地考虑不一定非要让每个人都在伦敦，这很有趣，因为多亏了 COVID 这个词，我们正在拥抱无论你在哪里，只要你工作得最好，就在哪里工作。
work best, I suppose. We do have some constraints, of course, like we are a UK-based company, and so we need to hire people who are eligible to work in the UK. But other than that, we are exploring more wide opportunities in terms of where people are, which is super exciting and interesting. Cool. If someone wants to come for a summer, like a co-op or internship or something, I know a lot of companies are just starting, especially when things are changing. They feel like they can't provide like
我们当然有一些限制，比如我们是一家总部位于英国的公司，所以我们需要雇佣有资格在英国工作的人。但除此之外，我们正在探索更广泛的机会，关于人们在哪里，这非常令人兴奋和有趣。酷。如果有人想来过暑假，比如合作实习或实习什么的，我知道很多公司才刚刚开始，特别是在情况发生变化时。他们觉得他们无法提供
a consistent sort of stable internship program. And I think, you know, I mean, I think we talked to Rob Zuber for CircleCI and and he kind of echoed that. And I mean, it makes a lot of sense, I think. I mean, even, you know, even bigger companies have a really hard time saying in January, OK, when you come in the summer, this is what you can work on. And so, you know, it makes sense. So is interning something that you're doing right now or not yet? Absolutely. We've in fact just hired an intern role for the next couple of months in one of our
一个持续稳定的实习计划。我认为，我们和 CircleCI 的 Rob Zuber 谈过，他也有同感。我的意思是，这很有道理。即使是更大的公司，在 1 月份说“当你夏天来的时候，这就是你可以做的事情”也非常困难。所以，实习是你现在正在做的事情吗？还是还没有？绝对是。事实上，我们刚刚为接下来的几个月雇佣了一个实习生角色。
positions. And we have had student level interns over the summer in past years as well, and have had some fantastic contributions from those individuals. And we don't have a specific program. I suppose we're still a relatively small business, but we're always willing to hear from people that are interested and willing to come and learn. And hopefully we all get value from the circumstance and produce some interesting things together. So I think that one of the overriding things at Zephyr is we're just always willing to have a conversation,
在过去几年里，我们也有过暑期学生实习生，并且从这些人那里得到了非常棒的贡献。我们没有具体的计划。我想我们仍然是一家相对较小的企业，但我们总是愿意听取那些有兴趣并愿意来学习的人的意见。希望我们都能从这种情况中获得价值，并共同产生一些有趣的东西。所以我认为 Zephyr 最重要的事情之一就是我们总是愿意进行对话，
be that with potential candidates, be that with interns, be that with our customers or those who are using our tools. We just always want to chat. So yeah, get in touch. Yeah, it sounds like, and please add color to this, but yeah, it sounds like one of the best ways for somebody who might be in college now or in high school now
无论是与潜在候选人、实习生、客户还是使用我们工具的人。我们总是想聊天。所以，请联系我们。是的，听起来，请补充一下，但这听起来对于现在可能在大学或高中的人来说，最好的方式之一
that's really interested in this is just to start using it. I mean, there's no barrier to entry here. Just start building some stuff and then, you know, they can sort of reach out or they could, you know, have a little portfolio and that can kind of get the ball rolling.
就是开始使用它。我的意思是，这里没有准入门槛。只要开始构建一些东西，然后他们可以联系我们，或者他们可以有一个小作品集，这可以推动事情的发展。
Absolutely. And, you know, it's very similar to, for example, if you're interested in computer game development, any of these technologies that marry creative work with technical work, be that so 3D modeling versus programming or web development versus graphical design and UI and UX. If you jump into a project of your own just because you want to
绝对是。而且，这非常类似于，例如，如果你对计算机游戏开发感兴趣，任何将创意工作与技术工作结合起来的技术，无论是 3D 建模与编程，还是 Web 开发与图形设计和 UI/UX。如果你仅仅因为想
make something, you end up touching so many of these different areas. And if you're early in your career, that will help you work out the bits that you're interested in, the bits that you're good at, and therefore the bits that you want to take further. So I definitely recommend people to just have a little think about something you'd like to see and then see if you can make it, be that a computer game, be it something AR, be it whatever you like. Cool. Awesome. see if you can make it be that a computer game be it something ar be it whatever you like cool awesome and so yeah this is this thank you so much for coming on the show yeah this is uh absolutely fascinating i mean honestly there's so much uh there's so much content here that
制作某样东西而投入到一个项目中，你最终会接触到这么多不同的领域。如果你在职业生涯的早期，这将帮助你找出你感兴趣的部分，你擅长的部分，以及因此你想进一步发展的方向。所以我绝对建议人们考虑一下你想看到的东西，然后看看你是否能制作出来，无论是电脑游戏，还是 AR，还是任何你喜欢的。酷。太棒了。看看你是否能制作出来，无论是电脑游戏，还是 AR，还是任何你喜欢的。酷。太棒了。所以，非常感谢你来到节目。是的，这绝对令人着迷。我的意思是，老实说，这里有太多的内容
that i'd love to really dive into um we've touched everything from understanding kind of high level geometry, random maths, all the way to building products. So thanks for your time. Absolutely. Oh, go ahead. I was just going to say thank you very much for having me. It's been a pleasure. Cool. Cool. If folks want to reach out, what we'll do is we'll post some links where folks can reach out to you. And also you can check out Zappar.com. That's with an A, correct? Z-A-P-P-A-R.com. That's right.
我真的很想深入探讨。我们触及了从理解高级几何、随机数学到构建产品的所有内容。所以谢谢你的时间。绝对是。哦，请继续。我只是想说非常感谢你邀请我。这是一种荣幸。酷。酷。如果人们想联系，我们会发布一些链接，人们可以联系你。你也可以查看 Zappar.com。那是带两个 P，对吧？Z-A-P-P-A-R.com。没错。
And Zapp.works is for the SDK. Yep, that's right. Absolutely. Cool. Thank you so much for coming on the show again um thank you listeners out there uh for all of your support on on patreon and checking out our audible uh membership and uh we will catch you folks next month programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and
Zapp.works 是用于 SDK 的。是的，没错。绝对是。非常感谢你再次来到节目。感谢听众们在 Patreon 上的所有支持，以及查看我们的 Audible 会员资格。我们下个月再见。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并
share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。